Yeah,
they're great.
We've got two of them.
I love it.
You could pick the front of the bag.
That's an interesting way to start to
your weight.
You can start it.
We're talking about these toilets that
have a built in.
It's not really a bad day.
It's more like a buck cleaner.
Right.
But the days are kind of crude.
You ever use it a day?
That's what it was.
It is,
but it's not good at it.
Know what I mean?
This was
this stream of water.
It was the perfect size and pressure
warmth and I have had,
I mean if we want to get into it right,
right off the bat,
I've had an anal orgasm before with a
vibrator and the only once in my life
and that day I was like,
if I stayed on here like 10 more minutes
I could get you.
I think it could a lot of gals out there
taking notes.
I was like,
I think I just use like diaper wipes in
my butt.
Yeah,
that's good too.
But I like think about it like,
you know,
like if my beard,
if I had like shit smeared all over,
would that be cool with the diaper wipe
and just going out in public?
I don't think so.
So the idea is to power wash it.
Yeah.
That's what that power wash my face
though.
I scrub it,
shower,
put my head in a tub of water for a
little bit.
They're very smart with it,
but day and the day never caught on here
in America,
they just went with paper,
which,
which gets caught in your butt and it
gets caught if you're a girl with not a
neatly tucked vagina.
Like most women,
little pieces break off ones that soft.
Yeah.
That's why I use Scott brand toilet
paper instead of Sharman.
Everyone thinks I'm being cheap and I'm
like,
no,
I just don't want toilet paper stuck in
my vagina.
You ever wipe your Dick with toilet
paper or not?
It's just your bottle.
No drip,
drip,
drop it right back.
Don't worry about it.
Not a concern.
I've always wondered that.
Yeah,
it's different.
I mean girls,
you know,
it's obviously it's not as efficient
delivery method.
Really.
Gotta be careful about the wiping front
to back.
What do you got?
Oh No.
Ryan,
you want to send my daughter once my
young daughter got sick from that.
I learned the hard way.
Yeah.
She didn't understand and we were on
vacation.
I actually got sick from it.
She gets a fever
I think.
I want to say she was three or,
oh wow.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
you want to like,
even if you tell them it doesn't make
sense to them,
you know,
back to front is the way you'd normally
it would go,
but then you gotta do it in your head.
You go that way until your arms get
longer.
Yeah.
And then you got to lift your leg up.
I can reach all the way around now.
Do you wipe your ass with your leg up on
the toilet?
No,
I stand up to wipe my ass.
I like to get in there squat though.
You could get into but whole area.
It's true.
I always do a captain Morgan stance to
clean out the area.
He has.
Oh and the leg up on the barrel because
when you stand up you gotta wipe and
wipe and wipe.
And when you're like,
what is this going to end?
Yeah.
Well that's why I think every toilet
should really,
I mean it would it be hard
to have one of those jet things and
every toilet it doesn't seem that.
I don't think that's a big ask.
Yeah.
My concern is so like if you're
squirting and then like poop crumbles
are coming out right,
and they're going back down.
Like could it ever then hit the thing
that's squirting on you and then could
poop squirt gun.
That's my,
that's my main concern.
Well there's bigger concerns in life,
but that is one.
No,
I mean we're just specifically talking
about toilet concerns that a major one.
I don't think that because of the water
pressure,
I don't think you would have to have all
like all of them,
like shit.
I mean it would have to prairie dogging,
right?
Yeah.
It would have to be like a cow patty
fiber diet,
who's already
anyway,
we're sex birth.
Well,
you're human.
Every new how sex is in some way.
A sexpert.
Yeah.
That's our platform because we don't,
we're not,
we're not experts at all.
I said the other day to corrine,
what's the name of the whole that hugs
the Tampon and she was like,
wow,
okay Christina.
That's the,
we did look it up.
Well,
because people call the whole thing the
vagina and that's inaccurate.
Vaginas are so complicated.
How the whole thing,
it's the thing is not a vagina and
that's inaccurate.
The just the,
the sex hole is the vagina.
No,
people call the whole thing the vagina,
but that's not technically accurate.
If the doors are closed and you look at
on the outside,
you'd go,
hey,
that's a vagina.
Like,
nope,
that's not technically correct.
My Labor.
Yeah,
that's Lavia you're looking at there.
Yeah.
Here's the church.
Here's the staple because the door,
the,
let me tell you how I feel about it.
I think it's fucking gross.
The operation where they remove labial
lips,
that seems so goddamn right.
Labioplasty yeah.
Somebody actually,
cause that doesn't do your vagina's
fully functioning and it works fine.
It's just the aesthetic.
And then if you get the surgery and it
goes awry,
that's not good.
Somebody had emailed us once about Dane
Cook had a bit about like meaty posy
lips a while ago and she'd got
labioplasty because of that bit.
And I was like,
no,
I like Dane Cook a Laba and I,
but I had talked about that because I
was,
I was watching his special and I just
put my hands over my face.
I was like,
this is not what we need it all.
But I was like,
surely no one's going to do it.
Cause he said that it's a joke.
He's a comic and he's a cute comics.
So then you're like,
should I do it?
Not me personally.
I mean,
but it also desensitizes the area a lot.
So you're,
imagine you're cutting meat stitching
things back up and things get numb.
Oh,
nice surgery.
And the slight,
there's a slice down my knee that I had
this knee operated on in 1994 and it's
still numb.
Oh whoa.
Yeah.
This skin,
like where they did what's called a
Patella tendon graft with,
oh my God,
they cut along.
Slice.
They took a piece of your Patella,
they pull that out and then they stitch
it inside the knee and that area in the
front where they took the scar,
like where the scars,
it's numb.
So just no nerves,
nerve endings there.
I don't feel,
well it feels notice will be different
than the sides.
Like that one strip where the scar is
very different.
So imagine that.
Sure.
Yeah.
I was like,
imagine your policies,
your knee and that just so what's the
point of life?
What's the point of living now?
I'm always just an envision your knees
as my pussy.
Whenever I see plessy knee,
it would be big
pussy too because it's little pussies
opening.
Yeah,
and that's why babies come out.
Otherwise you have to get c sections and
then the,
the baby doesn't get the product out of
China.
Juices on the baby and they don't get
the right healthy bacteria.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
I know why.
There's a notepad here.
I'm taking notes.
Underline this
baby born by Cesarean section,
especially elective Sicilian and
section.
It's actually unhealthy for the baby's
immune system.
I thought you were gonna say hotter
because you're placing your face doesn't
get sued.
Exactly.
They're not mashed when they come out,
they don't look like they've got a
facebook photo,
ratty face tune.
We've heard,
we've heard that.
We didn't know what phase,
tuning wise,
we've been in La for like three days.
We've heard face tuning it five times.
You know you can auto tune Britney
spears voice.
So it sounds listenable to the general
public,
but you can also do that to your fucking
face.
Okay.
So it's like,
it's an app and then beyond filters you
actually can take your finger.
And if my,
I think my face looks too fat,
I can smudge it in so that it's thinner.
But then you meet somebody in person,
they're like,
oh fatty,
all the celebrities do it apparently.
Oh,
come
on.
Oh,
not all of them.
Well not,
not you.
Well the weird ones do,
but it see,
the thing is like if you're doing that
and then someone meets you in person,
like that was the,
the issue with,
you know,
the Kim Kardashians,
Mexico pictures,
you know,
that's the whole thing.
Kim Carter.
You can imagine.
I love that you're up on this though.
I am a bitch.
Kim Kardashians brings photographers
with her and they pretend that she's
getting paparazzied.
Oh really?
She hires these people.
Then they take the photos and then they
doctor the photos.
They photoshop them and then they
release them as candid photos.
Well,
she went down to Mexico and some real
Paparazzi.
Were there some real unpaid ones and
they got unreached touched ashots and it
is a monster.
Really?
Well,
it's not cellulite.
Here's the thing.
It's fat taken out of her body and
stuffed into her ass to give her this
diaper.
Look,
it's a,
it's a meat diaper and you don't realize
how gross it looks until you see it in
real life.
I've seen one of those in real life and
it's chaotic.
Oh,
always seen him.
What pants on?
I haven't seen him naked,
but I saw one.
I was like,
what in the fuck are you doing your
body?
It's chaos because you suck and fat out
of your sides and your inner thigh and
all this.
Like,
look at that.
Whoa.
What in the fuck is that?
What the fuck is a diaper?
And to say,
I don't think it looks that bad.
Oh,
you're crazy.
Let's find the Mexico pictures because
there's the,
there was Paparazzi pictures of her
walking on the beach.
Okay.
Oh,
see?
Yeah,
that's not even the bad ones.
This makes me like
her more.
Why?
Because she's not perfect.
Humanizes her.
Okay,
but wait a minute.
She's projecting a face sheet section
and that's her business.
Anyone who thinks Kim guard issue cat
Kardashians actually perfect is
ridiculous.
We're young and impressionable.
People are held up to way higher
standards.
You look at that and you go,
oh my God,
how can I be like that?
That's a new role models though.
It's a parent's job or guardian's job to
step in and be like,
maybe you have maybe Ruth Bader Ginsburg
give her her to her.
Well,
that's true,
but here's the reality is if you're a
little kid and you're paying attention
to online stuff without supervision and
you're hanging out with friends at
school,
you're going to be affected by this
because this woman makes hundreds of
millions of dollars.
She's super glamorous,
she's on television and you find out
that she got fat stuffed into her ass to
make that thing cause she cheated
guided.
That's what it feels like.
It's like,
well if you're,
if you're projecting this image of
perfection and then it's like,
well no that's not really,
that's a lot of work to get the
Paparazzi that you hire to edit it and
then put it out like casually on the
beach.
In her defense it's a business or
businesses this looking,
I mean I don't even know.
It sounds like
I would just play a sentence to my child
and be like,
you know,
it doesn't matter to us.
You can say that.
You could say that,
but if you're a 16 year old girl and you
know you see her on television and you
see her popular at one time and there
certainly were people who looked hotter
but I still turned out okay and like I
don't by any means have a a perfect 10
bodies,
but she has confidence.
My body,
I don't have any problems with it and I
still ingested a lot of this kind of
like fluffy pop culture.
I actually love pop culture.
It's one of my favorite things,
like just inane information about
celebrities,
but this is a different kind of pop
culture because this is pop culture that
is famous for just being,
if this is what I would call it,
instagram culture,
like these instagram models and
everything,
you do have to be careful about that
because even I find myself at 32
flipping through instagram and going
like,
wow,
there's a lot of work to do.
There was some dude,
I don't know who he was,
some black guy,
I don't know.
He was,
he just was some funny dude who had this
video post about instagram girls saying,
I want to thank all my fans.
He goes,
Yo,
listen,
you don't have fans.
I'm just a pervert.
I'm not your fan.
He goes,
and if you keep showing pictures of your
ass,
I'll keep looking because I'm like that
shit.
Stop pretending that you've got some
talent,
people who love you.
That's uncomfortable
talent to have fans though.
Sadly,
you just gotta be hot.
I sometimes,
there are people who I'm just fans of
their ass.
You're not fans of anyone's ass bodies.
I guess I'm a fan of looking at Kim
Kardashian and I have no problem with
saying no.
I am enjoying funny.
That's where my point was pointing
it out.
Like you're like,
well,
let's go break it down.
Specifically.
Don't put me on this hierarchy of a fan.
I'm a down to,
you're jerking off team a bedroom.
Yeah.
I'm a fan of certain musicians.
Right,
exactly.
I don't follow you around this.
Some people do,
but yeah,
no.
Karen was always very naturally
confident and she's the only person I
know that's a woman that has actually
confident,
Eh,
you eat my snow.
Someone else they way.
No,
just like the way you are confident is
very unique because she truly doesn't
give a shit.
And I only talent and everyone comes up
to me and they're like,
it's Krinn.
Quinsig really insecure.
Right?
I'm like,
she's honestly not.
Thank you.
That's very nice.
Are you a confident,
are you insecure?
What's your insecurities?
Um,
I'm pretty confident,
I guess,
but everyone's insecure little,
a little bit of your own mortality.
You worry about all sorts of things.
We're going to die.
I'm constantly worried about that
constantly.
We're worried about everything.
You worried about your health,
you're worried about social status
position in society,
your friends worry about your health is
an insecurity though.
That's just carry the Kale security.
Like it's,
it's a broad definition,
isn't it?
Like we have to think of insecurity.
What do you think of just like how
people perceive you that don't know you?
I think it's,
you know,
constantly trying to make up for
something that you feel like you're
lacking in an area you're lacking in.
So a lot of people aren't confident in
their intelligence there.
How funny.
We know whatever occupation you are that
you're not the best in it.
I mean,
I constantly think I have things to work
on.
I'll never be satisfied until I'm the
best,
which will never happen.
So it's just a constant loop,
the best,
uh,
anything existing,
existing,
anything I want to do,
I want,
like I want to try to do.
And I don't,
I tend not to do things if I don't think
that I can excel in them,
which is why I don't have fun.
It's so true.
It's very true.
You don't have any fun.
We did go to universal studios
yesterday.
That was fun.
What do you mean by you don't have any
fun?
I don't,
I mean I don't,
I don't like fun.
What?
Yeah,
I have like a,
I have a bit about how I don't like fun
and I,
and I don't know,
I just,
I like working as opposed to fun,
like just frivolous fun.
If I feel like it's like a waste of like
just hanging out.
I have a hard time just like hanging out
like a hard time relaxing because we're
not doing something.
That's why I like hanging out with
Christina because me and my friend,
but we're also getting work done at the
same time or in universal.
We were in line,
we were creating the intro for the show
last night and we were all always were
always working.
Yeah,
that's cool.
But then I discovered psychedelics and I
feel like that's the only kind of like
that's the release that I need.
Hmm.
So you don't enjoy like recreational
activities?
Like you don't want to go fishing or
whitewater rafting.
So I feel like that is productive
because I'm making my body stronger.
So I do like stuff like that.
This is very analytical,
has to be a purpose to it.
I mean
I like skiing but it's because I was
like,
I'm doing something,
I'm learning a new skill.
I'm getting exercise.
Want a party with that girl?
No.
Yeah,
no.
I mean,
Gosh,
I mean unless
I'm drinking,
which yeah,
like dmt or some shit.
Yeah.
Then that's super fun.
She's so sweet when she's drunk.
It's so weird cause she like gives you
compliments and you'd never hear a
compliment from her and she,
she's like,
you like look really good tonight,
Christina.
I'm like,
bitch,
you wasted.
You always look good though.
I think it's important to just space out
compliments so that they're really
powerful when you space them out.
Yeah.
When you give them that ration them.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Exactly.
Interesting you see,
you seem,
you seem interested like what is going
on in your head right now?
Nothing.
Just trying to figure out why.
You know,
why you would issue fun,
why you would,
I mean it's not,
it's not a bad thing.
That's great that you're going to get
more work done but it has it served you
well?
Yes.
I mean we're sitting here because of a
great name for a podcast by the way.
I use you guys an example all the time
and when you do people email us,
they tweet us and we go up like 10
positions of the podcast charts.
All of them.
Like God Dad,
I know my manager was like the Rogan
bump.
I was like so cool.
I usually guys,
this is a great example of people that
didn't have like a big social media
profile or a big,
you weren't on big TV shows or podcasts
shot up because it's good cause it's
fun.
I like how you guys banter with each
other too.
You almost finish each other's sentences
and you almost talk over each other but
you don't.
It's like you have like you have a
thought and you'll interject with your
thought while you're having a thought
and then you pick up your thought right
after her.
It's like you guys have a ads.
We've been working together for many
years before the podcast so I think and
there was a lot of episodes of guys we
fucked that I'd have to go back and
listen to.
It will be very embarrassed by how many
times I interrupted the fucking guests
or her and so it's hard,
right?
When you're enthusiastic and you're in
his car and someone's talking,
you don't know when to do it.
Yeah,
but a secret twin language,
we've said like the same sentence,
a long sentence at the same time and
it's very creepy.
We'll talk with our eyes when we're
doing like a live show and know exactly
what,
what the next thing we need to do is now
when you say you guys worked together
before he did the podcast,
what'd you do?
We are a comedy duo is called,
sorry about last night.
So we did a standup shows me,
we were produced,
we the two woman show at UCB.
We would do sketches,
video sketches,
just shit.
Anything we thought was funny,
and this was one of the,
the impetus for the podcast was a
breakup crane got dumped in a Panera
bread and it was like the worst I've
ever seen anybody handle a breakup
meeting.
Like it really took a toll on her and it
was not good.
She doesn't show a lot of emotion.
So I'd like to see her cry.
I was like,
Oh shit.
And then one day she texted me,
she's like,
we should just interview every guy we've
ever fucked.
We'll do that on a podcast,
which is called guys we fucked.
And I was like,
yeah,
actually that's,
that's good.
I like how you call,
you call it an anti slut shaming podcast
too.
Yeah.
That's why that was my addition.
That needs to stop.
It's a ridiculous,
it's ridiculous.
And also you need to stop slut shaming
yourself.
I think a lot of people do that to
themselves.
And I got to say like I feel like guys
we fucked is the female Viagra because
it gets,
women have written us like I want to go
out and have sex cause now I know how to
communicate what I want.
I know it's not weird to say what I
want.
It's not,
I don't,
I'm not a slut if I sleep with somebody
on the first date or have a one night
stand and it's like,
that's really cool.
Well,
I think this country,
we still have the echoes of the puritans
that landed here.
I mean,
yeah,
there's some weird sexual politics that
go on in this country.
There's some weird way that we have a
viewing sex that I think is directly
connected to the original way this
country was founded.
Oh,
he's like some serious pr prudishness
that exists in America.
It doesn't exist in other places and
some people here,
it's a good thing because they think
that we get more work done because of
it.
That our society is more geared towards
productivity and getting ahead as
opposed to some societies that don't.
But if you,
if you stifle a part of yourself though,
that's going to come out somehow.
And that's why people sexually assault,
say the repression.
I think black people act out sexually in
any religion,
any religion that oppresses people that
were leaving.
It's like you're going to explode one
day.
Catholicism.
I mean,
it's the classic example and there's,
if there was as many people in Nascar
that fuck kids as Catholic priests,
how quick would they shut down Nascar?
Yes.
Very quickly.
Like religion is so controlling,
but you can watch documentary after
documentary,
you know,
the whole,
do you know the whole story about
ratzinger?
Who was the last pope?
He was,
uh,
he was wanted for crimes against
humanity.
I mean,
it's got literally cannot leave Rome if
he goes to certain places.
He could be tried for pro crimes against
humanity.
What he did when he was a bishop or
whatever the fuck the position they
call,
he was taking priests that were
molesting kids and covering it up and
moving them to another parish.
He moved one priest to a place where he
molested 100 deaf kids.
Oh God.
Damn.
Yeah.
And this was a hundred percent factual,
proven,
non speculative.
I mean he's,
he's responsible for moving these people
and the number of Catholic priests,
I mean,
first of all,
there's gotta be some Catholic priests
out there who were wonderful people and
I'm sorry you get lumped into this,
but the sheer number of Catholic priests
that have been involved in most dating,
molesting kids,
fucking stunning.
It's terrifying.
Yeah.
We had a guy emailed us,
so it was in Boston.
It was molested by one of the priests
and he got interviewed on the,
on the,
by the,
by that breaking piece about them,
we get w one thing I've learned from
doing guys,
we fucked all that.
I that really surprised me.
I feel like 85% of the population has
either been molested as children or
raped or sexually assaulted in some way.
Like some big way.
Not just like groping.
Yeah.
And it's,
I had no idea it was that common.
And then I thought back,
I'm like,
shit,
I get like one time I went to this
doctor because I had to get blood work.
So I picked a general doctor and he was
like,
it was this old man.
He's like,
I'm gonna give you a breast exam.
I was like,
Huh,
okay.
And then I,
and he went real slow with it and then I
left.
I had put my shirt back on and I,
when I left the doctor's
office and I was walking home and I was
like,
wait a second.
Ah God damn it.
I was so,
and I was like,
I'll let that slide.
And then I turned into a bit,
I was like,
you ever been sexually assaulted?
But she didn't realize until afterwards
there's been a series of doctors that
had been arrested for drug in their
patients and then molesting whether
under camera's like some patients with
suspected it.
And so they had done the investigation
and put hidden cameras and caught the
doctors feeling them.
I even caught doctors having sex with
patients while they were under.
These are things that I may be just a
neat to know.
There's some fucking creeps out there.
I know you're from Jersey as well.
I was born there,
but I only lived there toe seven cause I
was like,
my grandfather was in the hospital for
cancer when that angel of death,
I don't know if you heard about this
doctor that coming around like killing
people and we're pretty,
we're pretty sure that's what happened.
My grandfather died like pretty
abruptly.
My Mom's gonna kill me.
But she had said something to me
privately,
and I guess it was just two of settings.
You can't trust anybody.
It's not that you can't trust anybody.
He's like,
you're going to run into so many people
that if,
just like we were talking before the
podcast started about social media,
but like one out of 10 if you have nine
people that are awesome and then one out
of 10 is just a fucking creep,
you get upset.
God dammit.
Now think about running into people.
How many hundreds of people you run
into.
All it takes is one creep.
And so it's not that you can't trust
people,
it's just like you're going to run into
a certain amount of creeps just based on
the numbers.
The majority of people are not sexual
predators are not giant pieces of shit,
but the ones that are really stick out.
I think what you're talking about too is
big too about the suppression.
I think the suppression,
any sort of suppression of desires,
it,
it fosters that sort of creepy behavior.
It builds up and it looks for some sort
of an outlet.
And that outlet comes out in really
weird ways.
Like I have a friend,
well Jim Norton Pretty Open about it.
He loves dominatrix,
he gets,
he goes to them and all that kind of
shit.
And one of the things that he tells me
is that these ladies say that a giant
percentage of their business is like
really powerful ceos,
buttoned down men who have to like be in
control all the time,
have to,
you know,
have a very rigid,
uh,
profile that they're projecting to their
company.
And that these guys love to get shit on,
kicked in the balls and the love to be
told what to do.
Work hard,
play hard.
What's in there,
right?
It's,
there's a,
there's a thing that's happening to
people when you have to pretend to be
something that you're not.
Oh yeah.
That's why you find a lot of Ortho.
I'm Jewish and so like a lot of orthodox
Jewish men are veil.
There's a lot of,
you know,
hiring sex workers and it download and a
lot of,
I mean this is a very
broad statement to make,
but you know a lot of touching on the
subway kind of behavior.
You just see it more.
Did you see the,
they're making sex robots that would
look really,
they look like actual women.
I mean you could tell it's a robot but
it's,
it looks very close.
And I was thinking like,
because women have,
I think with women they oppress
themselves with their own sexuality and
I'm like man,
women are the ones that should be
getting this sex dolls because then we
can feel what it's like to have sex
without giving a shit what the person
we're having sex with.
Thanks cause it's a fucking doll.
And you could really go buck wild and
let loose and be vulnerable.
Be Vulnerable.
Brian,
if you can use a vibrator,
you could use a robot.
Yeah.
Oh,
I would love just sex robot.
But the robot do foreplay.
I have to get one of those toilet seats.
And then maybe,
yeah,
these are dolls though.
These are guys who choose dolls is their
life partners.
I did an article,
whatever you want to do,
what?
I wrote this article,
this guy contacted me and he told me he
had severe acne when he was young and
then he's disfigured and he's never had
sex with a woman.
And this is why.
And he said,
if you want,
if you want to ask me some questions,
I'd be happy to answer you.
It was all anonymously through email.
So he and I started going back and forth
about this,
you know,
cause he was upset that at the article
that I was mocking these guys that think
that this is their girlfriend.
Okay,
I see where you're coming from.
Yeah,
I see his point too though.
Imagine if you were just,
he has an insecurity and he didn't want
to be vulnerable with a person because
you're risking the rejection and that
rejection hurts.
But I feel like in addition to the
repression thing though,
I think masculinity,
I watched this documentary called I'm
the mask I live in on Netflix.
It's so good.
And it points out these little things
that little boys pick up like a,
um,
you know,
I was at a pool with my friend one
summer and this dad was trying to get
his son to jump in the pool and he was
like,
come on,
don't be a girl.
Jumped in the pool.
And then,
then he jumped in with those little tiny
things get in your head.
And it gets to the point where when
you're a grown man,
you feel like you deserve pussy.
Or the getting pussy or getting girls is
gonna make you up,
you know,
raise in status and that's,
that's
fucked up.
It's also a code kind of a perpetuating
cycle because if you're an idiot and you
raise kids that are idiots,
you know what I mean?
If your parents were dumb and they
raised you,
you might have some really shitty ideas
in your head that you've got to iron
out.
Yeah.
And sometimes it takes like a lot of
life experience to figure out what those
are and how to get them out.
If you,
if you ever are self aware of it.
And I feel like people go through their
whole lives,
they never know 100%.
I mean there's a lot of people you run
into that are 70 that are like,
I was watching this,
um,
video on youtube.
This guy looked like he was in his late
sixties,
and it was,
um,
giving some Asian guy a hard time on the
bus and he was saying all this ratio.
I watch that too.
He and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
this is an old guy,
old guy.
He also seemed a little not,
yeah,
he was a little mentally unstable.
I think that night I saw that video
actually,
there
was a guy doing the same thing to a
black,
uh,
that was at a Panera bread and there's
this black guy.
I was working there and,
but it's always an opinion.
We're trying to get them to sponsor our
tour
gift cards instead and give them out as
prizes is that just show
dealt with this guy.
But he wasn't old but he was saying the
n word like re like very,
I was like,
I want to intervene but I,
he might stab me,
just say that about someone to the,
to the employee and the employee was
trying to brush it off.
I'm like,
Oh God damn it.
That sucks.
And he was obviously,
I don't know what the hell was up with
him mentally,
but he had some,
some issues and he was talking to
himself and smacking himself and pushed
his chair over and picking it back up.
And I was like,
you need to get the fuck outta here man.
And then I like kind of like went away.
I'm like,
don't hit me.
And,
but then he eventually left,
but I was like,
fine line.
Like when do you intervene if someone's
mentally unstable?
You can't fix them now to shame them.
They're talking to voices that aren't
even talking to them.
You know,
if you say,
hey,
you need to get the fuck outta here.
Then they decided to shoot you and then
you're done.
Then employee like he know,
he realized that the guy wasn't there
like all there hopefully and was like,
this doesn't,
this doesn't matter.
This guy in the subway figured that out
too.
He was so chill.
Gay was,
I seen that a lot in New York City
though.
People that seem disturbed and then just
going off on racist rants to people or
their faces.
I'm like,
Damn.
A lot of homophobic grants I've seen
too,
like was straight up to gay people,
but I mean again,
people who are,
who are,
as you say off,
I mean there was a guy not too long ago
who just went up to the man sitting next
to me and he was like,
Yo,
I saw you looking at me.
You're looking at me.
I'm not like that.
I'm not going to fuck you and this and
this young woman,
this young woman did very much like
Kristina and I'm kind of just thinking
in my head,
I love to step in but that was not one
some ways mentally unstable,
it's we just all realized like,
okay,
we're not going to take anything this
person saying to heart so boys are so
weird cause you jam and that little
thing with people and they know you
can't get out.
That feeling of vulnerability is always
in the air and because of that people
that are fucked up,
we'll take advantage of that.
It's also a great,
great place for sexual assault.
Like all,
most of the sexual assaults I've
experienced have been on the subway,
just hard cox elbow in the motorway
stomach versus when you're on the subway
late at night and there's not many
people in the car and then you'll look
up across from you and there's this guy
with his hand down his pants.
He's going to town on his dick and
you're like,
I want to die.
And you make eye contact with them and
you're like fuck.
Or when someone sits right next to you
when there's absolutely no reason to do
that.
Yeah,
yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Wash it happens on the subway.
I've seen people take his shit
multiple times.
Once on the platform.
They just take a shit early in the
morning,
his bathroom usage time.
If you don't have a bathroom to go to in
the subway.
So do they do it on the floor to do the
over the edge?
On the floor?
On the floor.
I don't have that Guy Kersey.
C'Mon.
Yeah.
They don't want to get hurt like
homeless people?
I think so.
I would say yes,
but maybe one or two of them haven't
been.
I don't know.
We're just in a hurry or they be staging
caveman.
How many people have you seen shit on
the floor for?
Wow.
You've more than me.
I think I only saw two.
How many masturbator is have you seen?
Endless.
Ruined my favorite Mcdonald's for me
once I've ruined it.
Audition.
This guy like an Ellis,
he had like elephant titus of the Dick.
He's Dick.
He had sweatpants on,
but it was like a process.
It was like the size of that bar that
would inbox in his pants and I'm like,
no way.
And then he was like,
I'm like,
oh no,
totally fucked up the audition in the
pants,
but his hands were outside of the pants.
I don't know.
He was cradling it.
He's cradling it is just doing a little
jokey joke.
So I had a hard big cock.
He's one of those youtube pranksters
like that was his thing.
Hey,
if he was great prankster really thought
fucked you up for a couple of years.
Me Up for a while was just sell from
impractical jokers.
Trust.
Know that San Francisco,
they have such a problem with shitting
people shitting on this trip.
They have an APP,
they have an app where you could find
out where the human shit is and report
it so you could avoid it.
Yeah,
they have like piles.
San Francisco is super duper liberal
almost to the point where they're like
creative unless you want to share.
It's like they're just super open minded
lefties.
That's where we invited the homeless man
in San Francisco to do Karaoke with us,
but it was the best night ever lives
there and he was like,
well,
I think they're trying to combat that by
shitting on the street.
That's a good tactic to shit on the
street who areas that have been,
see there's like a can be near the
tenderloin.
Right.
That's probably where a lot of people
do.
They're shitting,
I love San Francisco by the way,
but one of the things about them is that
they're so progressive.
There's,
there's so left hard left that they just
tolerate shit on the street bowl in like
a really weird way.
The homeless people in San Francisco
tend to have a reputation of being
aggressive and we were a karaoke night
before I took the week cookie cookie of
dude,
I got it from a fan
now we've since learned
after our show here with her brother and
the
really fun and there was this homeless
guy comes up.
He was like dancing to the music and it
was like those scenes where everyone's
having a fun,
warm Christmas inside and then we'll
come in.
You want to dance.
We bought him beers,
went so well.
It was my brother reacted like you and
that's it.
Everybody else.
And then the match of the guys,
we fucked dowels.
Brought him in.
We did buy him a couple of beers and
then later found out he was an
alcoholic,
but he was already drunk.
So I was like,
Eh,
this is not the day that he was.
He was a veteran back on the wagon.
And I asked him about him and his life
and you know,
when was the last time you hung out
with?
Like,
I was just asking him about himself and
he seemed to really like the way he was
answering.
And it was like no one ever asked me
about me.
I'm like,
whoa.
He said it was like the best night of
his life.
And then he did mildly grew up
Christina.
Oh yeah.
But
again,
I wasn't on the week cookie at that
point.
Shit,
I really get groped a lot and I don't
know what situation.
It's like,
you know,
I grew up for your service.
Where did he grow up?
Me.
I love how I'm asking Kerryn where and
when I got slow,
I like a city released from the hug.
You know,
sometimes like normally when you hug,
you release out.
You don't have to slide to release a
minute.
Wait a minute.
He was drunk.
Right?
Who knows if he even knew what he was.
You know what?
I didn't care.
That was what he did pretty,
I'm pretty fluent in groping
millions of lines,
but she doesn't realize it.
Are you sure you have the same
definitions as her touching someone's
breast without them wanting you to
touch?
It is growing,
but it's tricky.
If you have someone,
you're holding them on the side and you
listen.
I'm not trying to know this guy lose his
cameo on house of cards.
It's fine.
I remember I say anything.
Then you're like,
no,
not the policy.
Hands off the
breast.
But you know,
it was an,
it was an area.
One of the areas I do remember going,
no,
no.
Don't ruin yourself for me,
please.
You guys were hanging out.
You had a few drinks and he got feeling.
Yeah,
but I didn't get,
I didn't care.
I was happy that he had a good time and
he was smiling.
Not because he wasn't smiling because of
that.
Hopefully like a spectrum for sexual
assault.
Yes,
there is.
There's like the casual,
like not quite touched your breasts,
but hey,
you went to,
you grabbed me right here is getting,
this isn't a hug.
You using your hands is underwire.
Right
under tick on your hands is not good.
I could feel breasts on a hug.
Chest to chest hugs are good because his
hands move to good.
Even though you can feel it with your
chest.
You're not a hurricane.
A hugger.
Odd Girl.
No,
she is a good way
stream.
I,
it's strange
to hug someone the first time you meet
them without knowing anything about
them.
Like I w we shook hands and when I first
met you and I will now hug you on the
way out if I'm allowed with your
consent,
I want to consent.
The was going for the hug and I was
like,
I don't know why he's thinking I was
comfortable until you just used your
hands.
Is The underwire now I'm scared or did
this,
I'll tell you that I'm very sensitive.
Breasts on my crest.
Mckee hug me.
I don't really have a sensitive your
face Danny Dick Style.
Oh yeah.
When a guy for five years,
man that's over,
jerked off in front of me,
open the door once my trailing is
jerking off,
knocked on the door and let me open the
door and he's jerking off and get into
your trailer.
I don't know what he was doing.
He was either being silly,
which is andy or he was high as fuck,
which is Andy.
He was looking to fuck me,
which is also Andy.
Yeah,
he should have been a number of
different things.
Stephen and I might see him as my
boyfriend and,
and we've,
we've met Andy,
we hung out with a new bunch of,
and it'll say in front of Steve,
like when you get to leave your
boyfriend and come fight where to stop.
Something like really funny in front of
Steven and I fucking love it.
Like I just get funny dude.
He is,
but he's,
he has no filter and he has no control.
And he wants to sometimes and like he'll
go on,
like he did my podcast once and he was
talking about being sober.
He's like,
I'm sober now.
I'm really happy I go,
so you're going to stay sober.
He goes,
I don't know.
We'll just have to see how it plays out.
It was,
but it was also one of those things
where you,
you understand his mindset is not like
he,
he's embraced his lack of control and
some sort of strange way.
Instead of like trying to re formulate
the way he views the parameters that he
establishes what for him to have a
healthy,
happy life because he was living in his
ex wife's shed.
He had a podcast called shed lights like
that.
Yeah.
Turn it into a comedy turn.
Turn your shit.
The shit show.
That's what he called it.
His programming is great.
Does your also remember that reality TV
show called the ass assistant,
which is to this day one of the funniest
things I've ever seen.
It's right where you like abuse,
potential assistance.
Just funny physical,
what?
Back in the days when people could,
you know,
just appreciate physical assault for
what it was.
Yeah,
let's go back to that time.
It's not the same with him because he's
so crazy and you know it going in,
but still,
if you're standing next to him and then
he just reaches over and grabs your tit,
it's still wrong.
Of course.
I have a love for him in my heart that
I,
that part of who he is is like kind of
like,
you never know what he's going to do
kind of thing.
To me,
I don't have it in my hand when I hang
out with them.
Like is it going to assault me?
Like I never,
I don't never think that,
but it's,
what I love about him is he's very
unpredictable.
He's a sweet,
you know,
and he's super
talented.
Like I would do scenes together.
I would have to Redo the scene over and
over again cause I'd cry.
Yeah,
it'd be a real problem.
He's really talented.
Yeah.
Well,
the thing with him is,
yeah,
when we met him,
he was sober.
So we kind of went into it knowing sober
Andy Dick.
And we actually met him at,
I mean,
I think it's supposed to be called these
days Rehab facility.
It was a halfway house.
And we met him and he had just,
I reached out and to his agent's
assistant and he randomly agreed to do
our podcasts.
We met him in the music room of his a
rehab facility.
And he told us the only reason that he
agreed to do the podcast was because he
learned,
uh,
in a that as a,
as an alcoholic,
he's been really selfish,
wasted people's time,
hurt people.
And so he said yes to doing guys we
fucked because he was trying to make
amends for all the bad he had done it.
And I thought,
I just thought that was really nice.
Like what a,
what a nice reason to do something.
Right.
But he didn't do any bad to you guys.
It sounds more like you want it to be on
your podcast because it's popular.
No,
no,
he didn't.
No,
he had no fucking idea what it was.
This was a couple of years ago.
I know.
Right.
I miss,
you know,
he was in,
it was,
it was a Karma thing.
I mean,
yes,
we aren't the people he hurt,
but I think he was just trying to put
good out into the universe and I really
believed him and that's not something I
would normally believe is like a year
and a half,
two years ago we interviewed,
it was a while ago.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's definitely had these moments of
clarity.
Yeah.
Well it was funny when he got fired from
this movie recently for licking somebody
and you said a misconduct is my middle
name.
I agree.
He's such a fucking care.
Those I think about like,
uh,
the Wiva I have a monthly show that I
run in New York City,
uh,
where my friend and I opened it up as
characters,
uh,
need.
And Simone were like,
prostitutes.
And where we have a guy,
this guy will comes up and he intros us
every month.
And as I'll,
I'll smack his ass and I've been
thinking lately,
I'm like shit probably shouldn't do
that.
Huh?
Did you ask him if it's okay?
No I did it.
I just,
I,
I he doesn't did it mine or if he did,
he didn't tell me.
I mean he hasn't and we were were brand
new take on it
is my take on it.
There's a difference between girl doing
it to a guy because a girl can't rape a
guy.
This is,
you don't have a physical advantage over
dry them.
You could do anything shore if you drug
them.
But like smacking guy in the ass is very
different.
There were some women who are bigger
than some men.
Sure.
Yeah.
This is where those are outliers.
There is absolutely the most part.
There's a difference between a girl
doing something like that to a guy and
that's the difference.
Yeah.
Cause you're no fear for your life.
It's the physical threats.
Well,
I got a buddy of mine who was sexually
harassed by his boss was a woman and he
said it was super fucking disturbing
cause he's kind of introverted and is
his boss would grab his ass when he was
like getting coffee.
Oh go to the coffee machine and she'd
grab his ass,
he'd Joel.
And he was like really stunned and
worried about being around her and she
would tease him about him being approved
and he said it made it really
uncomfortable.
And he said,
now I know what like to be a woman.
And it was joking around about it,
but yeah.
Did you ever address it with her?
No,
I think he quit.
Okay.
One up quitting.
It was a situation where I was like,
you know,
he was,
he was below her in the,
the social food chain of the office.
She was his boss.
She could fire him and you know,
he wouldn't have any money and nobody
would ever believe that she had done
that to him.
There was no proof there was,
it was a weird sort of reversal of the
dynamics.
And then that anxiety got created and
he's working environment.
I feel like women with women,
it's like little things happen
throughout your life when you're a chick
that just,
they're not,
they don't make you feel unsafe.
It's just like,
ah,
I just want to go to the God damn
grocery store.
Can you knock off to me?
I just don't,
and then that all adds up.
Whether it's big things,
little things is,
and usually it's a combination of both
and then that adds up to the feeling
unsafe and then you hear stories and
then you're like,
oh fuck is.
Well the cosby thing freaked so many
fucking people out,
but I know a bunch of girls who've been
drugged.
I know a bunch of girls who have been at
a bar and then how to drink that someone
gave them,
then all of a sudden their legs started
giving out.
Right.
[inaudible] as far as Ruthie,
Ruthie,
yes.
This part ended there though.
But yeah,
I was somehow got,
my friends were with me.
It was at a bar,
my own birthday party,
a cup maybe when I was like 25 in that
year of 24,
25 and uh,
I was pushed in my,
my friends pushed me in a cab because
they just thought I was like,
blackout drunk,
but I really had been roofing that
person's sins.
Committed suicide.
Yes.
I'm not the person who roofie do.
Yeah.
I'm not mad.
I knew who it was.
I'm not,
I'm not mad about it.
People are like,
aren't you angry?
I'm like,
no.
That person had demons so much bigger
than me getting roof.
He didn't,
I'm so thankful that nothing happened to
me.
Like I,
I feel honestly,
if that's what being a woman,
that when you get roofie to,
if you're lucky,
you don't get raped.
I feel lucky.
And that's being a woman.
Yeah.
It's weird to feel lucky that I've never
been raped.
It is.
It's a,
we're really luck because we hear about
it.
I mean,
now the public is hearing about how
often happens at Hollywood,
which a lot of us already knew.
But it happens in every economic status,
every class of people,
every eight.
It happens so much.
I mean we,
it's to the point where a couple of
times on our podcast,
I've said statistically there has to be
rapists listening to us.
Somebody listening to us has,
has raped somebody and I'm sure so
fucking sick of hearing it.
But I hear from the victims all God damn
day and I,
it doesn't help me get to the bottom of
why this is happening.
And so I'm like,
if you're a rapist,
make a fake email and email is,
because I helped me understand this
because I think about it all the time
because we are constantly getting really
pourable heartbreaking emails about it.
And we've had a couple of guys email us.
One Guy,
uh,
was,
he said he was really sick and tired of
seeing other men be Douche bags to women
lie to women.
And then they get laid.
And by the time he turned 30 he said he
broke and he started putting ads out on
craigslist and then would rape the
women.
Then he still does it.
But I'm like,
the problem there is you felt entitled
to a woman.
Okay.
Because he was acting like an asshole
that has nothing to do with you.
So I think that entitlement thing is,
is an important building block in what,
why people do this?
Well people start that.
One thing that does happen,
I've seen with men as they get older,
as they start to associate women with
pain because they get rejected and
because they didn't try to hit on girls
and they get shit on and they get
rejected and they get angry.
And then there's this antagonistic
relationship between women and them.
They look at women as the enemy and then
they look at women as the cause of
emotional pain and then they start to
insult them and say nasty shit to them.
I've seen it.
I've seen it happen with guys where
they,
you know,
they start off kind of like carefree and
then as they get into their thirties and
then they start getting more shitty and
then they,
well you see the arc.
I've seen the arc.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
A couple of guys.
Are they your friends?
No.
Okay.
I was going to ask if you've ever talked
to them about that because one thing I
think would help is if dudes were like,
hey,
don't,
don't do that.
Well,
one of the reason why I'm not friends
with,
and one guy in particular is because of,
uh,
extreme lack of awareness that became
more and more apparent as he got older
where you couldn't talk to him about
things.
And if you can't talk to some about
things,
if they're doing something wrong and
they're not going to ever learn,
and if they're not going to ever learn
and grow,
you're always gonna have this weird
blockade whenever you talk.
I hate that.
Yeah,
you can't talk to those people.
It's just not one system because that's
what that's he should learn.
Like,
hopefully if you lose it,
if his friends continued to do that and
he's like,
wait,
why the fuck weren't everybody go?
Some people deep
seated trenches,
these,
these defense mechanisms that they just
fall right into every time.
And it's almost like they can't stay on
the edges.
Yeah.
And whatever for whatever psychological
reason.
I mean,
I'm not a psychologist,
I don't know what's causing it,
but there's,
there's a lot of men that I think as
time goes on and they get,
maybe they're not attractive,
maybe they're not successful.
Maybe it's both.
But as time goes on,
they get more and more resentful and
angry about women.
Yeah.
Sometimes man,
we meet men that are,
you know,
and it's not often,
but you meet them and you're like,
you hate women,
you hate women.
And a lot of times I've been doing this
lately when we get like shitty things
said to us on twitter,
uh,
all respond back with like,
you know,
with a really nice thing to say,
like a compliment.
And then he'll,
it'll like break them down and be like,
Oh,
who's brief on phony?
And I'm like,
okay.
You know,
and it's because to me when I see a man
do that,
when they do it,
to me personally,
it's hard not to take it personal,
but that's,
it's not a personal thing.
They're projecting what they feel
do that to me all the time and they're
doing it because they just want to get a
reaction out of you.
And one of the best ways to get a
reaction down to you and make you feel
bad.
Yeah,
that's true.
If they say something nice to you,
you don't respond,
you know?
And then,
oh,
I just retweeted it.
Well let me try it.
Let me just,
I want it to be honest.
Maybe they try to respond.
Thank you josh.
Bond everybody.
Right?
What,
when guys do that to you?
Like what?
What are the flag tries to say mean
things Meghan call you a loser or
whatever.
And you know,
there's always someone who's trying to
push a button.
Yes,
I mean mean,
but why
do they do that?
This is the only reason cause they're
losers.
There's no one is like a happy,
fulfilled person who hates on twitter.
Doesn't exist.
Do that exactly.
I mean maybe you like I'm going to
dedicate five minutes a day to be in a
cut.
I'm just gonna go online.
I'm going to shit on people.
Then I'm might go after cut times over.
I'm going to just go water the garden
and be nice to everybody and be very
cathartic copies.
You wouldn't do it.
People need to squeeze in some current
time in their day.
I really think
the social media version of a rage room
where it's not really hurting anybody
and no it's no one's actual dishes.
You're breaking,
someone's just bought at a thrift store
and then you can let it out and then you
can let your punching back cause God,
John Ronson is one of the smartest
people we've ever had the honor of
talking to him and was super cry and
he's like when are we going to stop
making people are play thing or what?
What was the quote a week?
People are play things or play toys like
another quote that I don't know.
It exists in chickens.
You know,
like I have chickens and one of the
things you always hear about chickens is
the thing called the pecking order.
That shit is real as fuck and I,
we have a big chicken coop,
we have 22 chickens and one things that
happens is the chickens will find the
smallest chicken.
They fucked that chicken.
Oh my gosh.
The other chickens will pile on and
they'll chase the chicken around and
peck it for no reason and sound like the
chicken.
So anything like it's just a smallest
chicken because the chicken die
sometimes.
Sometimes chickens die and the other
ones will peck at the whole,
Oh my God.
And try to eat it.
Pitches being crazy terrifies her dogs
and dogs.
It exists.
There's the Alpha and then there's the
Betas,
wolf packs.
It exists.
I mean it's just a normal thing about
nature where when humans see someone
who's weak,
you have to work very hard to resist the
urge to go get the fuck Outta here,
get your shit together,
Pussy,
stop fucking crying like that.
That instinct to be cruel to someone
whose week is like genetically
predisposed and people,
it's a part of what made the genes of
the stronger people keep moving and ones
that were weak and they couldn't handle
emotional stress and then they were
shunned when they were pushed out of the
community.
But we're finding now with this new
society that live when we live in where
people are able to gather information
and communicate and doing things that
don't even involve like person to person
contact is that these people who are
introverts and these people that are shy
and maybe even like socially awkward or
have are a huge problem with
confrontation and you would consider
them week.
They have a type of creativity that
doesn't exist in the Alphas.
They have a type of creativity and they
have a perspective and it may be in an
introspective way of approaching things
that is super valuable to like computer
coding to a lot of other things that you
would normally think of as being um,
well they're not even normally think of,
but it's
there.
There are alternative methods of
thinking.
You would perceive that an outgoing
person would perceive that as like what
are you an idiot or something?
Well,
they don't exist in the [inaudible]
normal paradigm.
Like the,
like if you look at human societies up
until like the last couple hundred
years,
you're dealing with people that have
these hardworking jobs.
There's a few artists,
musicians and painters and things along
those lines.
But most of what you're doing,
if you're not a craftsperson,
hard labor,
very difficult jobs.
There's no computer coding.
There's no,
there's no,
well there's so many of these
alternative positions as far as like the
way the human mind works that were never
available to someone who lived three,
four,
500 years ago.
So we're finding value,
we're finding value in different kinds
of thinking and people with a different
people that are on the spectrum,
asperger's and autism artist,
while they have a different sort of
intelligence and we are looking at them
as if there's something wrong with them
because they don't,
they don't interact with people in the
same way as most people do emotionally.
And sometimes they have like a real
difficult funding,
difficult time finding emotional and
social bonds with people.
But when it comes to numbers,
when it comes to a lot of other things,
some of these people,
not all of them,
but some of them excel at those things
in a way that a lot of people can't,
aren't even capable of.
That's one of the things they say about
people in Silicon Valley that work in a
lot of,
a lot of these um,
jobs that involve computer coding and
programming and things along that lines.
You have a giant percentage of the
people that are on the spectrum.
Jonathan like it,
it might be like 90 [inaudible] works
there,
but he's,
yeah,
he's not,
he is mike much,
much more social than me.
You're not interacting with people a lot
in that job.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
That your bullock excel at that they
want done.
You know,
I think we have to realize that this is
like if it was for you,
the three of us,
there'd be no fucking cell phones cause
we were on a deserted island.
You could live forever.
The three of us,
we live forever,
whether it's his or her daughter and
shit.
The animals.
Yeah.
I've started a fire.
And we'd,
I'd show you how to kill animals and
maybe you guys could show me some
emotional intelligence.
Yeah,
yeah.
We can talk about working on feelings.
I could make you a beautiful,
like a mask for your face.
You'd have great skin.
Oh yeah.
The urge to be cruel to someone who's
weaker than you has to be resisted in,
in any sort of a comfortable society.
And that's not reinforced enough.
That should be on a bumper sticker.
That trail where I thought you were
going with this.
I thought you were going to be,
be like people who call a,
you know,
people out in a articles in jazz,
the Bellin broadly are really meek when
you meet him in person.
That's what I thought that was,
that's a good point.
That's how I wasn't sure.
And then I was falling and I was like,
that's not at all where he's going with
this.
No,
I think that's also true though.
My experience is
kind of true in a lot of ways.
But I think even what they're doing,
like I don't want to mention anyone in
particular,
but this one particular feminist writer
that I know who like will attack and go
after women,
she's like severely depressed and sad
hurt.
She's,
she's overweight and she's unhappy and
unhealthy and it's,
it's a,
she aware of that core.
Sorry.
Okay.
I got a mirror.
You know,
and you know what,
thank you for saying that.
Whether or not she revels in that
awareness,
right.
But that's more,
I guess what a lot of these people that
are calling people out,
look,
there's people that are calling people
out there doing the world a service
because they're exposing real
problematic behavior that I don't
expect.
Like,
look what I was talking about my friend
who gets sexually harassed by a woman.
I don't experience that.
Okay.
I don't have a job where I have a boss
who's a woman,
you know.
But if I was a woman and I had a boss
who was a man who was trying to fuck me
all the time,
it would be,
hell yeah.
You know,
what,
if you,
you know,
you're worried you have to be a certain
amount of flirtatious with this guy at a
certain level so that you can maintain
your position or maybe even like get a
job,
you know,
a better job or promotion.
I mean,
that's some real shit.
Yeah.
I mean it's also a place though too into
like,
even in comedy,
like when Karen and I started comedy,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm gonna I first made friends with
older male comics because it was easier
cause I hadn't,
it's not that we wanted to fuck each
other,
but I at least had some,
uh,
currency in the flirting.
Like there was currency in that.
Like,
no,
it can be friendly with them and they
will enjoy that and they would talk to
you.
Yeah.
You just need to find people who are
willing to give you the time of day.
And a lot of times like it's because I
want to look at you.
So you're just like,
but it's in a way that's not creepy.
They don't cross a line.
It's just,
it's just like,
we got our flow 40 and that's okay.
You're just using each other,
they're using you to feel good and young
and sexual and you're using them to get
comedy pro tip.
Yeah.
And none of us are being assholes to
each other.
I mean,
obviously we're talking about a bunch of
different exchanges,
but it doesn't always have to be
negative either.
Yeah.
You can just be friendly with each
other.
Yeah.
You know,
like I,
the last time I dated a female comedian,
we were both 21 you know,
and it was when I was in Boston and I
was like,
this is terrible.
Yeah.
As I say,
it sounds like a bull fucking crazy.
Sounds like the beginning of a bad
wrong.
It doesn't.
Yeah.
It doesn't work.
But I think one of the things that
happen,
and we can work comedian Thomson around
Christina possess gaelic super happy and
yeah,
they're both really funny.
Bonnie and red rash.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I'm Natasha and they are a great couple.
We found three thousands and thousands
of sure.
Interactions.
Meyers.
Yeah,
that's a good one as well.
Sometimes it works.
And we looked,
I hate absolutes.
Right.
I never do this or never do that unless
you saying like never eat babies.
Right.
That's a good absolute to have a good
one.
Nope.
Time.
Um,
but like also too with the flirting
thing,
I'm more comfortable,
there was a time where I look back,
I'm like,
I don't not friends with any big female
comedians.
It's only male because I feel more
comfortable going up to the mail cause I
feel like there's something of like,
I have something to offer only it's only
flirting.
That's it.
We're not going to,
I've never,
I've had been in a relationship as long
as I've been doing standup,
so,
but if not a fool,
I would have probably fucked a lot
comics,
but a better this way,
you know?
And uh,
but probably now
for sure.
But when I think of going up to
everybody,
I know it's great going up to a woman.
No,
no.
My boyfriend,
boyfriend,
my boyfriend's guide.
But you know,
in the past you could book a great open
mic.
Yeah,
good.
But going up to a female comic,
I'm like,
what do I have to,
why would she want to talk to me?
Because you're a human.
Why would,
why you may think of that?
[inaudible] want to talk to me?
Well,
you're looking at yourself as what
you're like the shit.
Yeah,
but I mean,
I've been doing standup for a long time.
I've always had men friends that are
coming in and friends and men and women
friends.
Yes.
I have friends that are female friends
that are comedians.
A lot that are on our same level.
That started in the same time as us,
but like,
you know,
a pro.
I remember when I asked Bonnie Mcfarlane
do the podcast.
I was really nervous to approach her.
She was super sweet and she was like,
yeah,
she's so supportive of other women.
Reach whining.
Just really champion championing women
aren't funny.
Her documentary.
Yes.
For.
I liked it a lot.
It's so funny.
It's really and really like raw.
Yeah.
Opened up about a lot of shit.
I surprised.
No,
I've known Bonnie forever.
We still have the same manager.
Oh really?
She's 1990.
Oh,
it was like,
was it mine?
Oh,
okay.
Or some shit like that long ass time
ago.
She's awesome.
But it's um,
it's a different animal when,
when you're a woman,
you know.
Yeah.
And I think that's one of the things
that I'm Eliza brought up when she was
talking about this a whole Louis C k
thing.
She was talking about how some men,
especially when she first started with
treat her because she was just starting
out,
she wasn't very good yet.
You know,
she was,
and someone who is established and is
better and really has like their careers
cooking,
they will look at you like you are a
lesser thing than them.
They don't look at you like a peer.
And I tried to tell this to as many
young comics as I can.
Um,
that is incredibly important that we
look at all of us,
all of us that are doing this thing as
the same thing.
Yeah.
Somebody might be doing it for three
days and someone might be doing it for
30 years,
but we're all doing the same thing.
We're all together.
Yeah.
So like doorman,
like I,
I'm super friendly with everybody who
works at the comedy store is a great
example that because everybody who works
there is a comic.
Like,
yeah,
the people who are the,
the security or comics,
a lot of people that were managers were
comics and people,
bartenders are comics.
I know like a lot of the people like
Josh Martin and Punky there,
they're fucking comics.
Even paid regulars and they still work.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's cool.
So there's a like an intense community
there.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
And then you never get a place where you
have a pro shows every night and an
indie show upstairs like that.
Never,
there's no place in New York that has
won multiple rooms like that.
A couple do,
but their not,
the quality of,
of the spectrum of,
of Comedians in terms of experience is,
is so vast.
Any night of the week there.
And it's so cool.
And that's really supportive.
Yeah,
it is a super support and people that
are not supportive,
they get pushed.
Oh,
and I love that.
I think the comedy community in New York
too was very supportive and we're very,
we do bet we give each other when,
when
we think of goods and it's,
we just,
we,
we talk about comedy,
we live and breathe it and we nerd out
on in the green rooms and we really are
supportive and,
and uh,
yeah,
I like it.
It's awesome.
It did.
Don't you guys think that now it's
easier to do that too because it's not
like everyone's competing for a very
small amount of spots.
Like it used to be like there was only
so many spots on a sitcom.
There's only so many spots to host a
late night show and everybody was like
hyper competitive.
Yeah.
Now
you're on opportunity.
Create your on saying,
I mean there's some examples of it guys.
We fucked one of them.
I'm broad city.
Yeah.
I love the story of broad city.
Abby and Alana couldn't get on house
teams.
They just kept getting rejected from
house teams at UCB.
They were,
they started working on this web series
together.
It blew up.
I mean,
the quality of the web series before I
made it to air is phenomenal.
They just put a lot of hard work into it
and they said,
we're not going to take no for an
answer.
And if this community that we've worked
in so long is saying no,
we're going to do it on our own.
And they did,
you can do that.
And also one of the things is that like
podcasters and people that do things
online,
they support other people to do things
online.
Like you never see someone from a show
on CBS getting promoted from a show on
NBC.
Right,
right.
Super Rare.
But in the world of podcasting,
it's super common.
Yeah.
Like everybody has everybody on their
shows and we always talk everybody up
and hey,
go see she's playing here.
And he's playing there and you promote
their dates and it's a,
it's a way more egalitarian,
way more like supportive community.
And it's a win win for everybody because
it never feels good to be supportive of
people you respect and admire.
Talented.
And you know,
and,
and it too,
that's why I love standup because you're
the only one who's going to do your act.
Yeah.
So don't worry about the company.
Hopefully.
That's true.
Yeah.
But uh,
but yeah,
I mean there's only one.
Yeah.
You and the people that are shitty to
other comedians they get,
I mean,
if you're a comic,
you don't have any comedian friends.
Like that's,
that's a giant problem.
Just like a
famous person.
Oh,
you can think of a lot of famous one.
Yeah.
Some famous ones that come to the store
and the,
the door people get super bummed out and
just look past them.
They don't say hi to them.
They'll go straight to bill burr or
straight to someone famous and only
talked to them and they don't talk to
regular folks,
I feel like too.
But I've had interactions with famous
comics.
Like the first one,
the person was being a dick and just
like looking down and,
and I was being introduced by his friend
and he was like,
hey,
how are you doing when it had sunglasses
indoors?
I'm like,
yeah,
but it was La Barf all over.
You gimme a name they rhyme with.
Well you're going to absolutely know.
But then the second time we met him,
if some couldn't have been nicer,
maybe going through some weird shit.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Somewhat run into someone like at the
wrong.
Yeah,
and I labeled them.
I labeled them an asshole though.
He was going through some shit while
showing pictures of himself to another
person.
But then is that how you act out
sometimes if you're having a bad day or
you're like,
just go right to naked photos.
Yeah.
Get those modes in baby.
Only if my ass,
I just show them my app.
Oh,
that's what I do.
Do you take nudes?
No.
Why not?
Thinking of doing it now?
Really just from two seconds.
I want to see your recommended it,
but just to be like a close up your
butthole.
Let's redefine the nude.
I don't have any that I need to show
anybody.
Yeah,
no.
Do you,
have you ever taken one?
I don't need to see it.
Uh,
I'm sure I've taken pictures of it.
Okay.
Really just for because it was,
cause you have a camera.
Good lighting,
dude.
He started taking pictures of
everything.
Take pictures of my policy.
I never taken a picture of my po.
I've never taken it as a check.
If you have a weird feeling down there
and just make sure everything's okay,
it's,
it's your own doctor.
If I was a girl,
I would definitely take pictures so I
would really know what it looks like
cause otherwise you can't really see it.
Just a gold squat.
A mirror.
Yeah.
Or you're super flexible.
You'd have to like,
oh Geez.
One of them tap around.
You've got to be a contortionist back.
See my own pussy from here.
Yeah,
but you can't because we were discussed
that you've seen the Labia,
you're not really sure.
We'll see.
Is the whole thing right?
The giant.
It hugs the Tampon.
That's the vagina would be the whole
thing.
I would say the Vaginas,
just the,
the,
the whole that we're most concerned
about.
The Pussy is the house,
but the vagina is like the living room.
Okay.
I think so.
Yeah.
You could be wrong.
He could be right.
And I honestly don't know which one it
is.
That's why we're relatable.
Were you,
when you started like being sexually
active when you were younger,
were you like a vagina?
How do I,
what do I even,
what do I do?
I,
cause I kind of feel like men going into
straight and by men that are going to be
having sex with women.
Like seib confusing cause it dick.
It's like you have to void the Dick.
Yeah,
you already have one.
But also like a woman as a woman who
doesn't have a dick.
I feel I know what to deal with it a
little.
Well guys share information with each
other to grow.
Share information about what to do with
Dick's.
Yeah,
I didn't know guys shared information
for sure.
Oh because we've heard a lot guys like
don't talk about it.
I'm like why not?
What you missing out on some tips?
What's some information you've got and
oh you just start talking about like a,
what do you do?
18 or 15 the 1st of May going out with a
girl.
Like you should let your finger.
Yeah.
Bring Nice,
clean being fingered at 14 is a fucking
worst.
It's just like Jack Camera.
Like someone's ringing a doorbell
inside.
Yeah.
They're not clean.
And there is no doorbell,
but they don't know that.
Oh,
you got to pretend.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It sucked.
Well jackhammer fingers,
man.
It's gotta be better now then when we
were young and it's gotta be better when
we were young then when our parents were
young.
That is very true.
It's all,
and don't think that's the same thing.
I mean I think that's with everything.
I think one of the things that's going
on right now,
and one of the things with,
uh,
all this sexual assault stuff that's
making the news is that we're,
we're in the middle of a giant social
change.
I feel that too.
And it's like our hurricane around us
and fucking bathtubs and are flying
through the
air and we're in the middle of it.
And I think a lot of times you don't
realize how much change is actually
taking place.
But if you just try to look at comedy
from the 1980s and look at comedy from
now,
like what you can get away with then and
we you like go watch Eddie Murphy Raw.
And you would never do that today?
No.
Carla like a lot of them had like a lot
homophobic shit.
But you know Andrew dice clay would
never fly today.
Maybe because he was a director.
I don't know.
I don't know that that would work.
He used to be Andrew Silverstein,
you know Andrew Silverstein was,
he would do straight stand up and then
he had a bunch of characters he would
do.
One of the characters he's just do was
the dice man dies,
man.
He put the jacket on,
do these nursery rhymes.
Fuck yourself.
He would just light a cigarette.
Yeah.
And then he became the dice man.
It's like more comfortable to be that
guy all the time.
Yeah,
that's true.
That makes sense.
It's comfortable being in a character.
I'm not my stage.
My bits are very,
well,
there's a lot of people that have done
that and they got trapped like emo
Phillips got trapped.
I Aye.
Yes.
I just watched a documentary at dying
laughing.
I think it's called and he was on hell
no,
he's not like that cause I saw him when
he stopped doing that.
He stopped doing that for awhile and
then he went back to it.
Bobcat goldthwait talk to me about it.
Like you talked about it on the podcast.
It was really hard for him to stop doing
it because everybody's like,
hey man,
do the Bob cat thing.
He's like,
Hey,
fuck you.
I'm just a person just going to do my
standup.
And he's like,
for a long time it was like really hard.
Oh that would piss me off because
everybody wanted him to go
this thing for the longest time and he
just got older and it was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Oops.
And it was really funny when he was
younger then it just didn't want to do
it anymore.
But if you have that character,
like if you're in a character all the
time,
you get stuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean we see hard to perform it never
feel like yourself.
That's what I like about it and that's
why their objections stings that much
more because like you were rejecting my
soul or rejecting you or what you're
presenting.
Then you really got to take a second and
think,
well,
I think for sure this is a tumultuous
time of change and I think ultimately
it's going to be very good,
but I think I got some weird ideas on it
though.
I really think that one of the things
that holds us up is the ability of ally
and I think that that's,
that is not forever.
I think the ability to lie,
like I think I,
I believe that we are,
I don't know how many years away,
whether it's 10 or 20 we're 20 whatever
it is,
years away of some Rosetta stone of
human interaction that takes place
electronically.
I think they're going to figure out some
way where we can teach children a
language that's a universal language
that's transmitted through computers or
through some sort of a human internet
interface,
some sort of a neural interface that
they're
working on hundreds of different
versions of this right now where there
they can already send thoughts back and
forth to people from the Internet.
They can send images to other people's
minds.
One person could send an image of a
triangle to your mind.
They can currently do that current.
Wow.
They do it through some sort of
electrical stimulation of various parts
of the brain where you send a signal and
that signal through your thoughts of
this object.
Like you have this idea like say if you
think of a bottle of water like well
something really a triangle.
Let's go back to that shape.
It's a very obvious sit symbol,
right?
You know what it looks like.
I know what it looks like and if I can
think of that,
there is a pattern in my brain that I
can transmit to you through this very
rudimentary technology.
So I,
I liken it to like a Morse code machine.
Did do,
they used to be able to communicate with
those as good as you get.
Now obviously you took a video on your
phone,
he sent it to someone New Zealand,
right.
It's,
we're,
we're in a different world.
It's not that far away.
I mean you're talking about just a
couple of hundred years.
We've gone from the Morse code to
sending a video to New Zealand in real
time.
Well have you ever heard of a Fisher
Wallace stimulator?
I've heard of that.
Yeah.
So my mom has had depression most of her
life and she was,
has been on 25 different meds and made
her worse.
And as a doctor prescribed a Fisher
Wallace stimulator,
it's just a little tiny machine with two
pads or sponges.
You what the sponge is a little bit and
you put them on your temples.
And she did it twice a day for about 20
minutes.
And her fucking depression went away.
And I felt,
felt like I got my mom like a,
you know,
cause she just,
it,
the meds would just make her so numb and
like emotionless and that would depress
her and she like,
I just lived my whole life I've been
seeing her do these peaks and valleys
and the Fisher Wallace stimulator,
there's no side effects.
If anything she gets a headache but
there's no mental side effects and uh,
and hurt.
It's insane how often the chef to do it.
She has it twice a day.
The only thing that I've noticed it,
I guess it,
this is a side effect.
It makes her a little bit hyper and not
hungry.
She's getting are both
hyper.
I'm trying to tell as many people about.
But I'm wondering if that's similar
types of technology that are already
happy.
What if it'll make you fucking ecstatic?
I don't know,
but that's what I was wondering.
I'm like,
Mako borrow.
If you slap that bitch on when you get
on that Japanese toilet,
hot water pumping up your claim like a
molly machine.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Put those babies on a,
I've got to go to the bathroom now.
That's great.
Yeah,
I just got to go light 20 milligrams.
I had a fan,
gave us a cookie in San Fran and uh,
it was labeled,
you know,
but I didn't know how much he ate and we
had to go on a plane.
So I'm like,
I'm going to throw this out.
And I was like,
at the end of a two week tour,
we're doing two shows and I was so
tired.
I'm like,
I don't want to get held up on the
plane.
So I took a little chunk,
I ate it and then it kicked in when we
were at the gate.
And crim was like,
I'm gonna go get starbucks.
You want anything like that?
Fine.
And
then all of a sudden I'm like,
no,
I'm not fine.
And I texted chrome like,
you're going to hate me,
but uh,
oof.
I'm going to die soon.
And uh,
this is not okay.
And then I just started having a panic
attack is already someone who is not
going to have flying.
No.
Yeah,
I would have panic attacks all the time.
And then there's like,
I was bawling my eyes out in this
little girl came up like two feet in
front of me and she was like,
and she just tilted her head and stared
at me and my career.
Why is she doing that?
That's weird.
Yeah,
it was.
I thought I was going to die.
I,
that's the only time in my life I ever
remember having the feeling of like,
you're about to die.
I got a nine little girl just came over
like a normal little girl.
And then when Christina said,
why is this little girl looking at me?
And I said,
probably because she's never seen a
grown woman have a tantrum in an airport
and anxiety tantrum.
And then,
oh,
getting on that plane,
man.
I thought I was gonna get kicked off
that plane.
She,
uh,
she almost did because it wants to it,
I think in 2017,
like saying did,
she's not,
I was like,
she's not good at flying like that does,
that doesn't fly anymore.
And,
uh,
the lady was like,
does she need to get off?
And I was like,
no,
she's fine.
She's going to be fine.
We're going to get through this.
We're going to get back home.
How far?
How far was the flight?
Oh,
it's from San Fran and New York,
right?
Yeah,
it was all cross country.
An hour after I got home to my
apartment,
she just put a blanket over her and I
was like,
why?
We're going to have like,
it was good.
It was,
well you wrote the Ro the storm.
I did and I survived.
Goddamn.
But yeah,
the edibles fucked me up.
Well,
they're just too God damn strong.
Especially if you just try to eat a
whole cookie.
That could have been hundreds of
milligrams.
I just took a little chunk of it.
It was a big ass cookie and I took a
quarter of it.
But then also,
well yeah,
quarter but that's why I'm scared like
Corindus psychedelics.
I,
I feel like if you have anxiety,
I've had a lot of anxiety,
probably not for me it's a different
thing because the anxiety that you get
from edible marijuana is very peculiar.
It's intensely introspective.
Hmm.
I don't love edibles either.
I much prefer mushrooms,
acid.
I did DMT recently.
I studied using partially using your
documentaries.
The thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It was very important.
I mean cause that's scary shit.
You need to study.
Yeah.
It's definitely not something you should
take.
No,
absolutely not.
I studied for,
I had it sitting on my table and I
studied for like a good two months.
Watched a lot of stuff on the Internet.
Right.
A lot about it.
Talk to people who had done it.
What's crazy is a natural part of human
neurochemistry chemistry that exists,
that your brain's making that stuff all
the time and then you can just extract
it from a thousand different plants and
then you take it,
smoke it,
and then you meet Jesus and aliens and
everything.
Have you met Jesus?
Meet everything.
Things that are changing.
So whatever the fuck they were a second
ago,
they're not the same thing a second
later shift.
This is pretty fucking intense.
Such a curious person and you really try
has,
has psychedelics made you cause people,
it really makes a
positive shift in their consciousness
and their curiosity.
I've seen it happen and sometimes it
goes the other way but um,
is that where we always are kind of
purposes
curious,
but it made my curiosity,
it confirmed the need for it like that.
If you do,
when you do something like Dmt,
it is so profoundly bizarre that after
it's over you are so stunned at how few
people know about this and how you
didn't know about until that happened
and how you'll never be the same again.
Oh you'll never be the same again.
No.
Right.
Are you never going to be the same
again?
Cause you know that's a real,
you know that you could go through this
chemical portal to what's essentially
another dimension.
I mean is it sounds like it another
dimension where you're,
you are interacting with ideas that seem
to be sent in.
They seem to be alive.
You're,
you're,
you're being inundated with thoughts and
words that come at you without like a
physical presence.
Like no one's saying a word.
But like if I said to you,
hey,
let's get a cup of coffee,
like that signal goes into your brain
because you're hearing my words.
You interpret them.
You get the same thing from these dmt
states,
but you don't actually hear the words.
But you know what the words are fucking
titanic.
Really Bizarre.
Have you ever seen a heel,
like a psych Akilah or have you ever had
I've ever heard a psychic surgery and
believe them,
so I,
okay.
I don't like,
I never really talk about this cause I
don't,
I don't need people,
I'm not trying to convert anybody to
believe in this shit,
right.
But I've had psychic surgery once and I,
and my mom and I had from this work,
uh,
so he,
this guy,
his name was Dr V.
Uh,
and
he did,
I did have my shirt off the,
that you wake up,
know what?
Ours is another revolution of another
sexual assault.
I was conscious the whole time,
but,
uh,
I like my mom had,
breast tissue that was really hard in
her breast because she had all these
surgeries for,
to get little tumors removed,
they weren't cancerous and it really
hurt or like if you've touched her boob,
like it would hurt and he,
okay,
so this doctor,
he used to work for NASA and a,
he's Russian and he,
he's very mysterious.
You looked into his background.
I tried to Google it,
but I didn't have the,
I didn't have,
it didn't seem,
which we're going to new,
a tiny little apartment and this old
lady was answering and she was like,
come in.
And I'm like,
but uh,
but he did,
he didn't touch her and he just,
he kept moving his hands like this and
he would,
he would do this,
like he was trying to get warm and then
he would flick it and then he would,
he would circle around her boob and then
pull out like an imaginary thing and it
was gone.
The heart tissue was gone.
It's the weirdest fucking thing.
And he did it to me with my knee.
It was the weirdest thing.
And I mean it's like seeing a ghost like
you.
You don't,
you're like,
I need that just happened.
That's undeniable.
Well,
if you believe in it,
your body can produce some pretty
incredible results.
And that's what the power of suggestion
is.
That's what placebo effect is.
Placebo effects a hundred percent real
totally.
But I didn't even know that psychic
surgery was a thing before he actually
did it.
I had no,
he's not doing anything.
He's just getting you convinced that
he's doing something and by him being
convincing you that he's doing
something,
you feel some sort of a positive
response because your body reacts as if
he's done something to you.
That's a service in and of itself.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'll take it is,
it is a service in and of itself,
but it's also deceptive.
There's a weird thing that people do,
like where they,
you know,
there's a lot of weird healers where
they do like Reiki and all this
different shit.
I am,
there's no science behind it.
It's not,
it's not real.
But if you think that it's doing
something to you,
you can feel better.
[inaudible] acupuncture.
I don't know anything.
I don't know.
I've had it.
I've had it,
but the guy was a quack,
but it doesn't mean that it's not real.
That's the I'm,
I'm very skeptical,
but I was working in a,
but that was like a receptionist at a
spa was my day job while pursuing comedy
and there was an acupuncturist there and
I was like,
let me try it.
Really?
I was in a really deep depression and
like the mind body connection,
I got to say she and she's,
and she's an md.
She's not just the person off the
street.
This woman's an MD,
a young woman,
and it,
it changed my life and I hate to even
say that I'm embarrassed to even be like
I have an acupuncturist.
It seems so hippy dippy mind
body connection is a misnomer,
right?
Because your mind is a part of your
body.
I mean it's all one thing.
That's why one of the things with people
don't have healthy bodies.
Yeah.
But if you don't have a healthy body,
your mind's not going to function at its
best.
You can be a brilliant person with an
unhealthy body.
Yes.
But you will be better if you,
your body functions well.
It's not giving you trump problems.
It's not causing you issues.
Yeah.
It's not a,
uh,
like a source of stress and concern.
And I think that what these people can
do or there's a lot of different things
that are not supportive whatsoever by
science and a lot of people that are
very scientifically minded,
they ish,
they,
they shun those things and they think
those things have zero benefit.
And they also put religion in that group
as well.
And I think they're very similar in that
if you believe in certain things like a,
there was a thing that,
a article recently by Robert Sapolsky
who is a,
um,
he's a out of state,
he's a professor at Stanford University
and we had him on the podcast.
We talked about,
um,
about primates and he's a really,
really fascinating guy.
Scott,
some amazing studies that he's done on
baboons and primate behavior.
But one of the things he was talking
about is the stress relieving aspect of,
uh,
an actual religious belief.
So you could say that if you really do
believe that everything's going to be
fine cause God's looking out for you,
that just,
that alone,
whether or not it's real or
scientifically verifiable,
that proof or it is not necessary for
you to feel good.
Yeah.
I mean I choose to be a positive person
because that's my survival mechanism.
I wouldn't have made it through life
without being positive.
Positive is one thing,
but an actual belief that something is
happening to your body that's not
scientifically possible like that
someone can rub their right I all the
bad juju out of your body.
Yeah.
But if you believe that though,
just the belief in that can trigger a
lot of what human neuro chemistry that
literally will make you feel.
That's true.
I can now,
uh,
after that experience,
that was a couple of years ago,
I can,
if I like lay on my bed and meditate,
I don't really do that cause I don't
have time.
But I can,
if I think really hard,
I can make certain parts of my body like
have those pins and needle feeling,
which I'm like,
that's cool.
You should make the time.
You probably do have kind of cool.
Yeah.
But it's weird like people worry about
like the discipline of doing something
like that,
that it,
it,
it gets them concerned.
Like I don't have time for that.
And they pushed it off because this is
something,
there's a weird way that human beings
are programmed that we,
we avoid certain types of strenuous
activity.
Avoid getting up early when you know you
should,
there's a lot of things that we do where
we go towards comfort and a way from
these uncomfortable feelings and some of
those uncomfortable feelings are just
sitting alone,
meditating,
just sitting alone and concentrating on
your breath for 20 minutes a day.
Yeah.
Big benefits to that.
But yeah.
And then you get down on yourself and
then that stress and then you're like,
whoa shit.
And then you're in your room all day and
you're like,
fuck that.
Then you go on the Internet and then
you're saying your room for another week
and then you read some bad comments.
He's just masturbate real comments.
That's the key to life.
Not really give a shit about the
comments.
I don't read them.
Yeah.
I very rarely will like glance through
and look really quickly,
but if I do it once a day,
oh yeah.
Well sometimes I want to get pissed off
and then sometimes we just make fun of
it cause it's so hot.
It's hilarious.
We've had like a men's rights activists
write articles about us,
like calling has come dumpsters.
I love it.
And I didn't know that.
I didn't know the phrase cum dumpster.
How'd you make it to this part of life?
I don't know.
Did you feel least barfed
first sentence in our book is,
are you a degenerate cum dumpster?
Unworthy of love and affection,
a zealot.
Somebody called you unworthy of love and
affection that we said that we had sand
in his cum dumpster.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
If he said that,
that would've made it even better
because then you would know like how
broken a person.
No,
we had an inkling.
That whole article.
Yeah,
it was fine.
But that's how I like,
to me that's the best feeling of like
hate taking control of the situation by
reading it and then roasting them.
Human intelligence is far greater than a
insulting
people.
Did.
You guys don't say mean Shit about men?
I mean you're,
you're pretty honest.
Yeah.
But you're not like anyone else.
You're not negative.
You're not like,
you're not like anti men.
Women,
you mean you,
you,
you rightly,
no,
not at all for shit that they've done.
That's fucked up.
But you,
you guys aren't,
we love the show is called guide.
We fuck.
Yeah.
It's not like you guys were spit on
guys.
We kicked in the Dick.
I love having sex with men.
I like how you guys say it.
Two guys.
We fucked.
And that's why to say it that way.
Fun Park yet.
But our,
her we're far definition of feminism is
women can be pieces of shit too.
Yeah,
it is.
And I think that for men,
I think it's a good
thing to be able to listen to women talk
unfiltered.
And I don't think and guys avoid that.
They go to war here with these bitches
have to say,
you should listen.
You should listen in,
in a,
not saying that you should listen
because you have to agree with them,
but you will gain a more of an
understanding of how someone who is very
different than you views maybe the exact
same interaction and just that,
just that one look at another
perspective might make you sit back and
go,
okay,
maybe I need to look at it from their
point.
Right.
Oh it's the best.
And my favorite email is when a guy
emails on and he's like,
I gotta be honest.
I listen to your podcast.
I was expecting to like jerk off and
shit,
but I actually learned something.
I'm like,
oh bless you.
I love you.
Jerk off and shit.
Sorry to disappoint.
But I know that I love that we like
that's the best.
When you,
when you,
when you surprise somebody I think is,
and the name of the podcast is people
are going to either go,
that's hilarious or that's discussing or
what,
or whatever the reaction is.
They're going to check it out.
They're going to remember.
They're surprised by what they hear
because it's not what they expected.
It sticks.
It's stronger.
Do you guys feel like the podcast has
helped you understand yourselves and
grow better?
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean that was it.
We had no choice but to grow.
When you have,
when you're sitting down with people who
you've had these intimate relationships,
uh,
both emotional and sexual with,
it's just like holding a mirror up to
yourself.
And that was the concept.
The concept was kind of to do this
podcast much like John cusack and high
fidelity and just learn about yourself
through these people kind of slide you
human yelp reviews.
Well,
don't you think?
You also learn about yourself from
conversations where you're not looking
at your phone,
you're not checking the internet,
you're not watching television,
just sitting there for hours
communicating with each other and that's
a lost art.
It is an eye.
We forget that the microphones are on.
We forget that we're talking all the
time.
Well,
one of the things that's changed for me
is I settle the podcast.
That,
and that was the first time I ever said
out loud.
I was like,
I really want to see my boyfriend.
Fuck another woman.
I just wanna like masturbate to it.
And then Steven and it must have been
like,
well he edits the podcasts and he's like
hey you want to uh tell me something.
And I was like what the three way thing
you want to see me.
I'm like Oh yeah.
And then we've had three ways and it
brought us closer and it's so hot.
So I have a cuckolding fetish that I
didn't even realize I had
queens queen.
That sounds so we don't say that one
cause it's,
that's what you type in to porn hub.
But it's like really cause it just cause
it's a chick but it's queen that Q,
u.
E a.
N.
It's just like cut.
It just sounds like q u.
N is queen.
Don't Google it.
No,
come on.
It'll be fun I believe yet.
Yes it's cut queen.
Cause I was looking up cuckold and I'm
like why the fuck can't I get shit?
And I'm like,
dissolve for men.
And then a duty male means like just
diamond cook queen and it's fine.
Oh,
okay.
That wasn't the whole thing though was
like guys that are like emasculated,
like some big black dude comes in,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Those I don't,
and
you cry in a corner and you jerk.
That's your lube.
Yeah.
And then one of them was like,
at the end of it,
the guy came in the other guy's mouth
and I was like,
whoa.
I made the guy that took another,
that's another category.
It wasn't in it in the first place.
It was all strictly for research.
Right at the end of it,
I was like,
rope,
this would that poor guy that just sits
there and pretends,
I mean it guess it's a guy who wanted me
to suck a dick and they brought him in,
they gave him a script and he's like,
okay,
I need to see these imt.
But I mean the,
the,
the thing that they're projecting like
this,
this vision of like this poor guy who's
with this hot girl and he can't control
or any,
can't satisfy or,
but they're together.
And then the big blackout comes over to
sit the fuck in the corner and watched
me,
fuck your woman.
And then,
and he's like,
do you watch just a couple?
Okay.
Uh,
what were you researching?
I don't like
that's what you're talking about.
Googling a product.
Yeah.
And know how I got there.
Somebody probably googled it for me and
then made me look at it.
It was like,
I don't even orgasm
my pants off this.
Do you watch a lot of porn?
That a lot.
What's that to you?
What's not a lot like once or twice a
week.
Oh yeah.
That's not a lot at all.
Yeah.
I think porn is like anything else.
You can get obsessed with it.
People get obsessed with all sorts of
things and the porn gives you a
stimulation,
right.
And that stimulation is,
you're watching two people sexually
interact with each other and you can
pretend you're there.
You can pretend you're doing it,
whatever weird stimulation it is that
that like weird thing that you're doing.
People will numb themselves with that if
they have too much stress.
If there's too much going on their life
and the it,
it becomes almost like a drug.
Yup.
And then after you're done jerking off
and you call me,
you're like,
well why was I even doing this?
What?
I'm going to go eat cake and it's just
sadness.
That can happen too.
I was like,
can you say I feel pretty good after but
I don't consume a ton of porn.
Yeah,
I was getting too much.
I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to try masturbate into my mind
and it's a lot more work but it's more
rewarding.
I love masturbating to I my imagination.
I've got to start masturbating natural
people.
Yeah I know people you know like truck
drivers.
I don't know any truck drivers
using,
if you weren't using your real people,
were you cleaning Pten,
creating beans in your mind?
Yeah,
the sims and my head.
No,
just imagining my boyfriend fucking
somebody else.
Oh like a real hot chick.
Cause I'm like,
I always think so high other people,
and normally not my boys,
but I,
you know,
I'd never allow my brain to like let's
masturbate to like a that neighbor guy
that we had or airbnb.
Goddamn.
And I did masturbate to him and it was
really fun because cause I'm like,
oh what are you playing a new game?
And we got a new kid.
It's like candy crush.
Yes.
But it's really fun.
It's like you can go there in your head
and he doesn't know that.
So it's cool.
You didn't hurt him,
you didn't hurt your boyfriend and yeah,
I didn't hurt anybody.
It
doesn't seem the same as if you found
out that a,
that you know is
jerking off to you.
I just don't want to find out.
But if you're doing it,
that's okay.
They shouldn't dm you and tell you like
so many men do.
It's like you keep that to yourself.
I don't mind if people jerk off to me,
but I should never know about it.
And we agree there's a difference
between a girl saying that she plays
with herself to you versus a godsend
that he plays with them or a girl,
a girl saying it to a guy is different
than a guy saying it to a girl came up
to me is like I jerked off to once.
I'm like,
no,
I don't know.
I get excited.
It depends on how much schlage has.
You were attracted to him probably.
I mean,
and that's,
and that's this thing that we liked to
pretend that's not true.
Oh my God.
If he was like this hot,
sexy guy and he told me that,
I'd be like,
well like that article that I was
pulling the sit on Joe's toilet for a
little bit,
an article that I pulled up before we
started the podcast.
Well there was a that a women and
straight and gay men are more attracted
to good looking muscular men,
which shows that we're not making any
progress with sexual gender stereotypes.
Like no,
that's not it.
And that was like Newsweek or it's the
same.
This space go to the safest space,
which is my favorite,
one of my favorite twitter pages because
they will retreat the most ridiculous
social justice warrior men with muscles
and money are more attractive to
straight women and gay men showing
gender roles aren't progressing.
It's in tech and science.
First of all,
it's not tax,
but it's not science that has god to
have nonsense by a male.
Sydney are female.
I need to know,
I mean,
it matters not showing gender roles
aren't progressing.
Yeah.
Neither does hot stays hot.
Stupid.
No.
It's like if you use a lighter and you
burn your skin,
it stays hot.
We're not progressing in our ability to
defuse fire with your fucking skin.
To me,
I like it because that means you're
driven and you don't sit on your ass all
day.
No one wants to fuck a lazy person.
I mean,
if you do,
that's your own thing.
But uh,
but also muscles.
You don't like monster.
I was gonna say,
I was like,
I wasn't surveyed for that,
but I'm more attracted to somebody who
truly like comedian,
like funny.
When you're funny.
That is so much hotter to me.
You could be overweight,
you can be under what you could be
whatever.
When you're funny.
Well,
isn't that the thing about what is
attractive is that everybody's got their
own little thing.
There's,
there's some pretty standard things,
but then
when that go left or right and a bunch
of different weird ways and that's kind
of one of the cool things about being a
person.
You know?
I know some women that are into like
really skinny guys,
like super skinny like ribs that heroin
looks.
Some girls think that's high.
I can't see that being high.
My boyfriend is always like,
I want to get skinny.
Like iggy pop.
I'm like no sex.
Then chunk stars.
That's my
God.
It was like a guy with like a legit gut.
That's like Dave.
I mean the Dave Matthews that people
love that.
And if David,
Dave Matthews lost,
he has a little belly.
Yeah.
And if he doesn't have that belly less
hot.
Have you ever been attracted to
somebody,
made you feel uncomfortable or attracted
to them because it's not your type,
but usually just take such great care of
his body working out and we're like,
we like fat three Paul
triple out and get a donut machine.
Definitely
rooted out by weird stuff like the
skinny one.
The skinny ones were because that's like
an unhealthy thing that could be looking
at someone and they look like that.
Iggy pop look is like,
boy he doesn't look healthy,
was still using drugs and he still
skinny.
But it just Kinda,
I think I like a guy that's bigger than
me though.
Like physically bigger than me cause I
like that.
Cause then when he hugged me exactly,
there's a,
it was pretty good
actually.
I take that back.
He's got some muscles and he did a song
with Kesha.
That's an old man too.
I mean that's impressive.
He's 60 years old.
They're
like,
yeah,
that's him.
Young
man gets so much harder as they get
older.
There's some women though that just are,
so we went to this summit that was like
a lot of females.
It was just female speakers,
but women of the year summit chick's
doing rad shit.
Right.
And this woman Sheila Nevins who's the
head of documentaries at Hbo,
I've never heard of her.
She is the sexiest woman I've ever seen.
She hurt her style and her confidence is
very,
she's very graceful.
But then she's like,
just because you're a woman doesn't mean
you're good at shit.
And like she just is very,
she has this realisticness to her that
I'm like,
you are so sexy.
I don't give a fuck madness.
That's the only a woman over 50 can have
beautiful
in a way that,
cause I think sometimes young women use
like I don't give a fuck,
but like you give so much like Fox and
there's,
when you,
when you truly don't give a fuck,
you don't need to announce the person
posted the most pictures of the
relationship isn't the one in the worst
relationship.
When you've got to say it,
it's sorta like really depressing.
Strippers always have instagram pages
that have a lot of like inspirational
quotes.
Memes.
Yeah,
a lot of memes.
Memes.
Like you know,
I get so depressed at strip clubs I
really can't handle.
I Love Strip clubs.
I love a hot chick dancing on me with
her titties and my face.
I just want to cry every time.
We have nothing in common except our
sense of humor.
That's what it is.
We like laughing at dark shit,
like,
like laughing at something that's real
fucked up is the best feeling ever.
To me,
that's the same relationship I had with
my brother.
We're polar opposites except we share a
sense of humor and I love that he's one
of my favorite people in the whole
world.
I mean you don't have to be the same.
No,
we are not that all the same and it's
nice to see like I think a lot of people
like seeing two women that like just a
disagree on a lot of shit,
but it's,
that doesn't mean I don't like her.
Yeah,
that's a problem too is that people get
so married to ideas that you don't like.
People who don't think the same way that
you do,
which just seems to me to be kind of
crazy.
That is a dumb thing right now.
It's really ramping,
right?
Identity politics and this idea that
like you have to be on one team or the
other.
You've fucking just dig your heels in
and fight the other side with tooth claw
and nail.
What did we see that strongly in?
Politics.
Right.
And it's a gigantic issue in politics.
Politics is fucking,
it's exhausting,
but you can't,
people can't live in the opposites.
Like you can be both things.
You can be a great comedian and you
could also sexually assault people.
Like he can be kind of Shitty in there,
but you still look good.
That doesn't,
don't you think that the Colussy k thing
was extra disturbing because he was
doing it to one of us.
Uh,
he wasn't just doing it.
It wasn't just saying,
hey girls,
stay still.
I jerk off in front of you,
which is gross.
But he's also doing it to,
it should be appear.
Exactly.
And that's why it's one of the case.
To me it's a power dynamic.
And it's a,
you could have had a sex work,
you could've jumped off,
a sex worker would have been thrilled to
take your money,
and you could do a scenario where you're
blocked the door and you jerk off and
she's like,
but that's a conceptual thing,
right?
That's why that indicates that meets the
power struggle because that consensual
thing doesn't give you the buzz that
causes the,
for Beth thing,
that also says to me though that Louis
is so intelligent that he did think it
through a little bit more than he's
letting on because it's like,
you know,
they're going to have to keep this
secret because we're all in this club
together.
So if you do it to a young comedian,
I don't know about that.
There's certain thing about standups.
I think everybody will agree we're
impulsive.
Standups are impulsive people.
It's one of the reasons why you'll say
the funny thing before everybody,
some people might even not even
entertained the thought.
You opened the door and then blurt it
out quicker than everybody else.
There's an impersonal aspect to that.
So you think that could be an impulse?
No,
I think that he's an impulsive guy.
I think most comics are,
and there's a wild thrill to that
impulse.
The problem is you're also doing it to a
person that doesn't want you to do it to
them.
And even if you don't,
there's no physical contact.
You're making them watch you beat off,
which is fucked up.
And then,
you know,
the whole tig notaro thing with tig.
Notaro thinks that he started helping
her to show that he was a nice guy cause
he's like a lesbian and a feminist and
like he's going to promote her thing.
And this is like take some of the weight
off of him.
She said that she felt burdened by her
relationship with him because she
believes that he did it on purpose and
he made a conscious decision.
It could be,
I don't know.
You know,
it's a good,
it's a good branding move.
It's a good,
uh,
let's try and save the reputation,
but I don't know.
I don't know.
But,
but with that though,
it's like the,
when he hosted snl in the monologues
about pedophilia and he's like,
he related it to like eating a snickers
bar.
You want to touch that little kid so bad
and you know how horrible and
how many lives it ruins and how fucked
up it makes you,
you know the kid,
but you still do it.
Like that's what I think that with what
he did,
I'm like you really wanting to do that
real bad.
Cause comics all knew,
we knew about it current and I knew
about it five years ago.
Yeah,
I had heard it.
Yeah.
Wasn't true.
And I had heard from someone who knows
him better than me and I said,
well what do you mean?
And they gave me like this weird
scenario where he was joking around,
they were all joking around together and
then the story got out and you know,
like he like pulled his dick out like as
a joke and everyone was laughing and it
was like he was being silly.
And then the real story came out.
But I think,
yeah,
we've had people like the Ari Shaffir
was our podcast.
He pulled his,
the,
I mean he,
he did ask,
but like that was fine.
I wanted to see his dick.
I want to see had a vasectomy.
So we wanted to see the scars.
I mean,
there was a reason and then also that we
had never seen,
um,
someone who was not circumcised before
and then he was like,
do you want to see it?
And where they'd said yes.
Does that think about that cutting baby
Dick's is so common that you guys have
gone through all your life to adulthood.
Sorry,
shift more than the average person
should fears
first.
Dick,
do you saw that wasn't sliced open as a
baby?
It wasn't [inaudible].
It would dick that was uncircumcised.
This was none of these are two separate
dates.
I can't believe I've never encountered
an uncircumcised penis or he's a super
Jew.
Of course he's circumstance.
I was like,
I got the longest balls in the game and
I'm like,
I mean,
shown to me,
right?
Like I want to see them and I'm like,
damn you pretty gross.
Grapefruit and an old lady's planning.
I've seen,
I've seen ours,
Dick and balls multiple times.
That's one thing that male comics do.
You,
they're done showing each other's dicks.
I've never showed my pussy to anyway.
Chris [inaudible] senior places not,
I didn't like,
it wasn't a big pussy.
She didn't see your vagina.
I saw it all.
Yeah,
I know.
I didn't open up sliding.
I like show you saw the staple.
I saw the,
yeah.
That's just because here's my tv set.
Here is my kitchen.
I over slept for a flight and woke up
drunk.
That's why she saw my vagina,
my pussy.
That's a different story.
There's no like,
genital mutilation tradition amongst
women and people will say,
Oh,
you're looking at it the wrong way for
skins,
not mutilation.
Bull.
The fuck it isn't.
It is.
Yeah.
I saw a truck in Union square a couple
of months ago.
That's like a circumcision is male
genital mutilation.
And I was like,
oh,
it is.
Yeah.
A lot
of kids lose their dicks from it.
Every year.
Perfections.
Yes.
Not only that,
there's so much shit.
There's a famous story when it comes to,
uh,
there's a baby that was raised and
raised as a woman because they did a
botched circumcision on the kid when it
was a baby and the his penis
essentially,
there was a massive infection.
They had to remove his penis.
And because of that,
um,
they had made the decision to try to
transition this person into a woman.
And so they transitioned this person to
a woman and they gave him hormones,
but he always wanted to be a man and it
was like super confusing to him that he
eventually wound up committing suicide
when he was,
it's a horrible
story.
Please leave
your response
connect.
It is,
but what do you do when you cut off a
baby's Dick?
I did it.
That's the question.
When was the teacher wasn't a time when
you can try to reconstruct or they did.
This is the only,
they've only started putting new Dick's
on people,
but in the last year I think there's
actually only been yes,
I think there's actually only been one
or two successful penis transplants.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean it is huge.
It is harder to create a penis and it is
create a penis.
You take it from a cadaver.
Well,
whoa.
It's not the same as I may dig where and
when you transitioned male to female,
you're flipping,
you're flipping the deck,
but they're add,
they're adding on cadaver parts when
they're going female and a male.
No,
this isn't what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about someone who's Dick
[inaudible] who lost their Dan accident.
Okay.
Lorena Bobbitt.
Yeah,
I was going to say cut off her day.
Yeah.
Well they reattach that,
but that thing,
and they found that in the field and she
likes you throw out the window.
The window.
Cause she should have through that in
the river.
I mean,
yeah.
There's another story about a woman in
Orange County who tired her boyfriend up
after she drugged him,
tied him up and then cut his dick off
and threw in the garbage disposal.
She's,
she's in jail.
She shed be though.
Yeah.
Bad Ass.
But would you say that if a guy did that
to a girl,
that's horrible.
I have a bit about like,
uh,
lost his penis during circumcision 17
years ago.
Undergoes worlds third successful penis
transplant with is a color discrepancy
that surgeons will fix with tattooing.
I mean,
all right,
you got it.
A penis transplant,
I wouldn't know.
Complain about the color.
Crazy.
So goddamn crazy.
People lose their dicks because of
circumcision and then when it's not
totally common.
I mean it's,
it,
it's rare,
but it happens when you're a cadaver.
Who gets your dick taken off to put on
another person?
D is that the,
the,
when you check the box on the back
driver's license to donate your organs,
like it's all right
for grabs.
Like yes.
Yeah.
Wow.
I'll just put that out there.
If I die,
take my deck.
Go ahead.
That's really nice of you.
The thing is,
um,
it's probably really hard to get it to
work right?
To get all the,
I mean,
it's theirs.
It's a such a complicated organ.
There's so much going on in there as far
as all these different connections and
apparently the operation takes forever.
It's a long crazy operation.
Yeah.
Kicking balls are so mystical to me.
Hmm.
Balls.
You ever stare at your balls and they
just think it's like there's an alien in
it.
It's like they just move like an octopus
or something.
I definitely weird.
It's so weird.
The movement.
The first time I gave a hand job though
did surprise me.
The balls.
I know the shaft.
I didn't realize it was going to like
move with me.
Oh,
the skin was going to like,
I didn't say that out loud,
but definitely thought at weight.
The skin moves with you.
Yeah.
Where it's like,
so I thought I was actually just to be
like sliding on my hand up and down.
But if there was a little like a give
there.
Mm.
A little gift.
I thought that was a,
Andy's rocky.
Oh,
I thought it.
Okay,
I'm going to revisit that later.
That's her boyfriend have a tech.
He does have a dick.
Well,
he did say God,
that's our first three way I,
this girl gave him a Ninja blow job.
Like it was so impressive.
He came right away and I've never,
I've sucked his dick many times.
Still do.
That doesn't happen.
And uh,
I was in the corner going,
Huh,
okay.
You were in the corner of the bed.
I was not terrorism but uh,
you know,
I was like Oh word.
Okay.
Which,
and it was,
you know,
I stole the areas to see what you were
doing because we learned this year
Christina has been giving blow jobs.
It's all wrong.
I didn't know you had to suck,
suck it when you go up like a fleshlight
is pleasurable because of the suction
and your,
when you suck a dick you're supposed to
like suck it in as you go.
Read a little airlock,
little suctioning.
I was just liking it like a lollipop
and you know,
no one told me cause they're probably
just happy I was there.
I don't know cause I'm like I don't
really love giving blow jobs but it's
like Christine is like,
I love it.
I'm like,
yeah cause you're not doing it right.
I know.
I was just licking the dick the whole
time.
I would also like,
well because it is a job,
Joe a leg,
he's gonna hate me.
My boyfriend takes like,
it takes a long time to calm and so,
I mean just at a certain point your
mouth is uncomfortable.
That's why I don't like hand jobs.
I'm like,
you do it.
You do it better than me.
I like watching you do it.
Why?
Why are we sitting here and I'm trying
this,
you know,
unless you really want me to,
but I'm like
gone.
Are you comfortable talking about sex
stuff?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Do you have sex toys?
You sex toys?
I used to have a flashlight.
Was one of the sponsors,
the earliest sponsor of the podcast.
But you didn't,
did you use it?
Okay,
so that's a sex toy friend doesn't use
them.
Anyway,
I,
we,
he dated a famous porn star right before
me and I discovered he could held on to
her flashlight while Hurricane Sandy was
flooding my apartment and curtain was
over comfort or very uncomfortable life
preserver to them.
It's not telling you?
No.
I picked up,
I do a bit about this,
but I picked it up and I thought it was
a flashlight and I thought he'd thrown
it away and I was like,
oh,
that's a butthole.
Okay.
I have a little talk on corrine leaves
the bottle one.
It's just crazy.
They mold it.
Yeah,
I mean obviously not the internal parts,
but the outside like they literally like
put like,
like rubber on and went to the place
where they do stuff.
We went to the Doc Johnson factory,
which is in Los Angeles and we saw the
chair that looks like an ob Gyn chair
where the porn stars and there was like
remnants of like whatever the stuff this
and mentee stuff that they're putting in
their body.
Like this is stuff that we're taking
picture right.
Disneyland.
It's our Disneyland.
But when you jerk off with a fleshlight
are
you closing your eyes?
Are you looking,
are you imagining because they make it
look like an actual policy.
But if that,
that's what I thought.
They also made it look like an alien.
They made an Avatar one at one point in
time.
Whoa,
I'm in a blue one.
Like you know,
fuck that big blue lady that out.
But it's just a,
it's just a little bit of a tube.
It's just the part you need.
You know what else they make that I
thought it was hilarious.
They make them that are like,
you know those tall boy like pabst blue
ribbon cans.
They make them out of that.
So you unscrewed that.
It looks like a camp.
You would have it in the freezer.
Yeah,
exactly.
The pussy from your wife.
Have you ever seen those little,
uh,
we'd be like one of these cavemen Nitros
but you screw the top and you could
stash money inside
than it used to put my house keys.
It does not look like a rock.
Classic.
Rock and [inaudible] leave my key in the
door and it would be less obvious than
this rock.
I go one over a friend of mine's house
and he had fake rock speakers in his
backyard,
but the fucking do look like rocks here.
This is not what real rock pressing.
No one
is.
It's those fucking catalogs that they
leave on planes.
I love those.
Remember those?
You'd be going through those.
I need that six foot big foot statue.
My fucking my backyard.
Yeah,
he watches over the garden man.
Fake.
They make torsos.
You ever seen one of those?
It's just a chick's torso.
Well it looks like those sex dolls,
you know those real doll things.
You know they have a brothel in Germany
now where it's like a sex doll brothel
in your house are
so bizarre.
I wouldn't be comfortable with that.
Yeah,
there it is.
Probable Brothel.
The Johns or getting too weird.
But that again would come in and pay off
in the same hole.
Would you ever fuck a sex doll for their
story?
We could talk about on the podcast.
I'm not stupid so I wouldn't think it's
a real person because I think was she
beating off and then like when you're
going so far that you're fucking this
rubber thing pretending it's a person.
You're taking it to a totally different
place.
Like you're not in a fantasy land where
you're masturbating or watching porn and
porn,
aren't you thinking our guys,
when they watch porn,
like she's sucking my Dick sorta watch
porn.
You just thinking that the activity is
exciting.
Like the activity.
Someone sucking a dick as excited and
then you would like it if they were
doing it to you,
but you're not thinking,
oh,
she's doing it to me cause you're not.
Oh you're not.
Not,
you're not stupid.
You know,
but they're not their suspension of
disbelief.
It's like when you see a movie,
like,
you know you're at a theater,
but if you're like holding onto some
cold rubber and he got her to cold
rubber feet in the air and you have a
rubber pussy.
Oh that was the other thing.
The Guy told me that I wrote that
article and I was going back and forth
with him.
The guy with a relationship with,
he said he puts her in the,
her in the tub.
She,
he fills a tub with hot water to heat up
the temperature of the body.
Oh,
oh,
I mean that's,
yeah,
it does seem like real murderer.
So weird.
It's very strange.
I want to go over to his house but not
hurting any.
What do you guys think?
Like if there is like this is theirs.
Do you know what crispr is
withdrawing the bottom of me.
Your Fridge?
Veggies.
Probably not though.
Yes and no.
It is that.
But it's also a new thing that they're
allowing.
Um,
they're,
they're starting to experiment with this
new method of altering,
uh,
DNA.
And they're there,
they're figuring out a way to do it with
non-viable human embryos and they're
starting to do it with humans now that
are alive.
And one a guy was recently one of the
first people to be injected with a DNA
from crispr.
And as Crispr gets more and more complex
and more and more effective,
they think in the future,
you're not only going to be able to pick
like what happens to your children,
like what your children are,
what they look like,
what traits they have and don't have.
You literally going to have like a
laundry list of things that you could
pick and choose.
But you might be able to do it to
yourself.
Like they might be able to accelerate
the,
the actual capabilities of this
technology to the point where you could
take you and you'd say,
I want to be a six foot three black
woman.
And then they shoot this stuff inside of
you.
And then over the course of like how
ever long it takes to alter your body,
this is all speculative cause this,
this guy was just the first guy ever to
this recent guy.
See if he could find that,
makes
a ton of those people out there.
But this,
um,
this technology's not going to just
change the way you look.
It will literally change who you are.
It's going to stretch your legs out.
It's going to change your features and
what's in the way your brain works.
They think they're going to go knock out
Alzheimer's.
They're going mail stop.
A lot of the genes that allow people to
have Parkinson's and a lot of different,
different ailments that people have.
They've isolated those,
those genes and they think they can shut
them off.
Whoa,
cancer.
I don't want to live to be 150 I'd be
able to go,
this is what's going to get really
weird.
Like you might not want to,
and you might say that,
but maybe if you're 80 and someone says,
hey,
you want to be 30 again,
you might go,
Whoa,
he was in good health.
I wouldn't mind it,
but somebody might be willing,
I mean it might physically be possible
for you to not just look 30 but beathard
like literally change your cellular
structure
to the point where you're a young person
and that's going to be the destruction
of our society.
Modifying your own jeans is just an
injection away
if you're feeling lucky.
Cause right now it's very experimental.
Um,
but this is a seat,
but this is just speculative.
There's an article with the very first
guy had it done.
Yeah.
Very first use of crisper on a living
person.
Uh,
so this is like,
you know,
there's this body acceptance thing,
right?
Like I'm happy with who I am.
Be Happy girl,
be happy boy.
Be Happy.
We are,
you're happy until someone comes along
and says,
hey man,
you,
you could be thor.
You know,
you want to be thorough.
I have to do to be thor.
I'm not willing to make any sacrifices.
No,
you just go to the thor doc.
It's like Halloween for life.
Yeah.
He shoots a thor shot and your ass and
you look like that.
Christopher,
whatever his name is guy.
And could you,
you think you would be able to change
it?
So like one day I'm thor,
but the other next day I'm Cindy
Crawford and might be able to,
well,
probably going to take a while for your
body to shift to whatever form it's
going to morph.
And maybe if you keep doing it over and
over again,
it's like a vhs tape where you keep
copying it over and over again and just
scratch.
You might put some errors in your DNA
and grow some extra feet and weird shit.
Fun,
exciting.
Who knows?
I mean,
listen,
there's gonna be some early adopters
that are very upset and have buyer's
remorse.
There's no doubt about that.
Yeah.
And then what do you do when that
happened?
What do you do?
Sorry,
but it's like plastic surgery you can
alter,
I mean you can't obviously those,
there's limitations for plastic surgery,
but that don't seem to be on this.
Hypothetically if it goes as far as it's
like plastic surgery in the sense that
there was one way they used to do it,
which was awful,
and now they're way better at it.
Yeah.
Sometimes you can't tell.
Like boob jobs.
Yeah.
My boob jobs now they make boobs that
are soft.
They're smushy and you could,
when people's don't.
I've met a couple of girls that are
like,
yeah,
these are fake tits.
I'm like,
yeah,
can I touch them?
And then when you touch them,
they feel like a boob.
Yeah.
The crazy here.
Or touch a fake boob.
It felt like a real boob.
Not No,
but I've touched fake boobs.
I let that alight.
Yeah.
I like fake boobs.
I think they're kind of the fun.
They are fun.
What do you think joe there?
Well
the real is better,
but it's weird.
Like you people accept fake girl parts.
They do not accept fake boy parts.
It's really interesting.
And yeah,
calves and shit.
Like what?
What is it?
Fakes.
I know guys that have at peck implants.
Calf implants.
Yeah,
it did.
They look,
can you,
can you tell that they're obviously he's
dead.
Oh it's cause he had it and had a lot of
issues and he's getting a lot of weird
surgery and one of the things he got was
peck implants.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's nice to know that sometimes men
can be just as insecure as living,
but again,
that's not imposes them.
That's synthroid.
What that guy's doing is he's injecting
oil into his muscles,
muscles larger and bolts and stop.
It's not healthy,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Those guys getting massive infections.
You're,
you're shooting.
I didn't even know you could still could
get cancer.
16th Century
Shit.
No,
no.
Mitch Hedberg,
Mitch Hedberg before he died,
um,
a couple of years before he wound up
overdosing.
We were a stand hope and I were hanging
out and he got the call that Mitch was
in the hospital for gang green shooting
heroin into the same spot over and over
again.
Oh,
okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
You can get gang green for sure.
People get it today.
Shit.
Yeah.
Fuck.
But um,
the thing is like,
you should be happy with who you are if
you can't change it.
The we're getting into is this weird
place in the future.
Do you found that article while you're
out there?
Google apps.
I found I have jumped on that,
that there was an article from very
resells 16 that said someone in China
was really,
really recent.
The recent,
within the last couple of days,
it said,
man becomes the first living patient for
crispr.
They injected Crispr DNA.
What's in it was in the last week or
two.
That article,
I'm typing that in.
It says it's from 2016 and the recent
ones says there's 20 embryos.
They got check.
Little search.
Really recent.
Really,
really recent.
Have you ever had a poop enemas?
Yeah,
I found.
Found the guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Genes altered inside a person for the
first time ever.
This is it.
Exactly.
In a bold experiment that has never been
done before.
A man had his jeans altered permanently
and attempt to cure a disease.
So this is one step and this guy had a
disease and decided to take this chance
and do this and to scientists for the
first time.
I tried to editing the gene inside the
body in a bold attempt to permanently
change a person's DNA to cure a disease.
The experiment was done Monday in
California on 44 year old Brian Maddix
met do I do,
um,
through an ivy,
he received billions of copies of a
corrective gene and genetic tool to cut
his DNA in a precise spot.
Uh,
it's kind of humbling to be the first
test said Medu who has a metabolic
disease called Hunter Syndrome.
I'm willing to take the risk.
Hopefully it will help me and other
people will good for that guy,
for being the first guy to take that
chance because that's one of the things
that they need is they need someone
who's willing.
Yeah.
And He,
like I said,
as an early adopter,
they'll learn from him and maybe be able
to improve it.
But the point is this is happening at an
incredible pace.
Crispr was just discovered a few years
ago.
There's a great radio lab podcast on it.
It's spelled c,
I think it is.
I think it has an e in it.
But if you look up the radio lab
podcast,
it is fucking phenomenal.
And it's,
it's crazy when they explain how they
discovered this and what the
implications are.
I got to tell my mom about that.
She's got so many health thanks.
And neurological and every doctor was
ever in Canada is like,
I don't know why.
Sorry.
And she's like,
really?
Was she around like any sort of like a
farm?
Yeah,
the only thing,
uh,
she,
she's pretty sure she had lyme disease
and she didn't know I have lymes
disease,
but uh,
I got,
I got the bullseye right away and I got
the antibiotics.
Now they give you two weeks antibiotics.
I only had 10 days at the time.
So I feel like maybe I need to go back,
but I don't,
I don't,
I have a very sensitive stomach.
Uh,
and that's all,
that's all you have is a motherfucker
fuck you up.
Yeah.
It doesn't get any worse and worse and
worse.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes.
Not Good.
Yeah.
But I need something like 60% of the
ticks and the upper Hudson valley have
lyme disease.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
Something insane.
Like it's really high levels and it's
all over the east coast.
And you know for a long time doctors
didn't even know what the fuck
that was.
Oh yeah.
But that's what I'm pretty sure cause
it's neurological for all her shit
neurological and she has like,
she has an Arachnoid cyst and the base
of our stem but they don't know if it
was there when she was born in
[inaudible] arachnoid cyst.
Yeah.
It's just like a spider says kind of.
It's like a big ball.
And then it like wraps around her,
the base of her skull and the top of her
spinal cord.
Yeah.
And they think she just got diagnosed
with dementia and they think that
possibly draining it would do something
but they don't know.
But then she just got half of her
intestines taken out.
She has,
she's the one of the 3% of people who
gets a bell's palsy and it doesn't go
back.
Oh God.
And she's trouble get bell's palsy is
from lyme disease.
Oh re.
Oh yes.
I remember reading that because I didn't
know you could get bell's palsy and then
it goes back to normal and it's more
common.
It's like 97% chance your face is going
to go back to normal.
That the atrophy that happened.
Wow.
A friend of mine,
his son got it.
He was really young and they brought
him,
the son got lyme disease and he brought
the son to the doctor and doctor didn't
think it was lyme disease and then
finally the kid had bell's palsy and
that's when they realized and then they
started giving them like the series
antibiotics and [inaudible] son was very
young too.
I think he was only four at the top.
Yeah.
Intense.
She had a,
she had a stroke though when she gave
birth to my brother.
My older brother are first kid and uh,
that's then after that was when the
bell's palsy happened.
So I'm like,
it's,
I guess it's the connected to that.
She,
she's like a walking health question
phenomenon.
Yeah,
she is.
She is crispr.
Yeah.
I'm sound like June.
That shit probably could help
actually.
Who knows.
I mean we'll see what happens to this
guy with hunter syndrome boat if this
really works.
And this is all,
like I said,
this discovery of Crispr is only a
couple of years old.
They're already starting to use it.
I'm living humans.
She's at the end of her rope to the
point where she would say whatever do
it.
I don't care cause I feel like she'd be
a good candidate for that.
See,
the thing about lyme disease too is that
it has a neurotoxic element to it that
it causes like mental disorders.
Yeah.
It's also curry.
It's connected to something called more
challenge disease.
Oh,
I've heard of that.
I don't know what Joe does is like
people start thinking they have fibers
growing out of their skin.
They started scratching themselves and
yeah,
and the,
the hallucinate.
I did a TV show about it and one of the
things that I found that was fascinating
was there was one doctor who was like a
legitimate doctor who had more
gentleman's disease and it was
explaining the hallucinations that he
would have while he had,
um,
because he had lyme disease.
Well.
And he was thinking that when you get
bit by a bug and that bug has like lyme
disease and tick diseases are very,
they vary and they vary in intensity and
they also vary in how many different
different pathogens that tick and
contain.
And so the way he was describing it to
me,
it's like you're talking about one
symptom,
like a,
something that happens to you when you
have a host of different pathogens.
And he said some of those pathogens he
believes contain neurotoxic elements
that causes people to hallucinate and
why those hallucinations is they think
that things are growing on their skin.
And they started scratching themselves
and he was seeing it on his eyeball.
He was saying,
you look in the mirror and he would see
something crawling across his eyeball.
But he knew knew wasn't really there.
Fuck.
And because he was so smart and because
he was a doctor,
he was recognizing like,
okay,
I am,
my brain is malfunctioning.
I've got a real issue here in the toxic
element of this fucking lyme disease is
spreading through his body and just to
come to it.
Yeah.
And so he would,
he,
the more challenges like widely
dismissed by a lot of medical
practitioners is beans a psychosomatic
disorder.
They think that people are just crazy
and they're hallucinating,
but he's saying yes,
but if you look into that,
they almost all have lyme disease.
Oh,
okay.
You're saying it is connected and people
are missing this connect.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I have.
I,
yeah.
And I feel like we've,
we've always debated my mom and I that
for mental shit is from that,
from limes and then like I've haven't,
I don't have many symptoms of lines.
Well,
one thing I've been getting lately,
like the past maybe five years,
it's anger attacks like fucking rage
that I can't,
I have to do something to get it out of
my body because it's watching that girl
suck your boys deck.
No,
I liked that though.
But that was fun.
How come I was jerking off to it?
Uh,
no,
but it would just come out of nowhere
and I'm like,
it feel,
it felt like,
I felt like the incredible hulk.
Like you wanted to,
it's some medical issue that something
was going on.
Like there was a,
uh,
like there's like a problem I go because
it didn't,
it wasn't attached to hormonal,
wasn't pms.
I also have bad pms,
but that's more anxiety.
It's not anger.
I would get these like anger attacks and
I would have to scream,
oh,
my poor boyfriend.
Like I would scream.
I still do.
I will scream into a pillow until I
can't talk anymore.
I polyps on my vocal cords and I feel
like that's mom help one.
But it's,
I need to get it out.
I don't punch somebody,
but I need to break something or I need
a Pi or you need to hurt myself so I can
feel embarrassed and then come down from
it.
But at least you confirmed my suspicions
that all funny people are fucked up.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I got it.
Well,
you don't,
you don't seem very fucked up.
Yeah.
What's your fucked up?
You fucked up and what?
We did it out,
but from martial arts,
but it,
my whole life I've beat people up.
Vote.
No,
no,
not,
but I'd been in five competitions.
Yeah.
Oh,
but that's healthy though.
And then,
yeah,
maybe not.
Oh,
I got hit in the head a lot when I was a
while.
Your brain works well.
You got a lot in there.
Yeah,
it works pretty good,
but it's also,
there's a hair trigger there.
There's a hair trigger mechanism.
Always wants it to flip off and always
wants to go dark.
You did.
Oh Wow.
What could we,
what would trigger
do at an event?
Like some,
some someone doing something bad,
something happening where I'd to you or
to anybody?
To anybody.
Not to me.
There's just a,
there's a,
there's the anger switch where I'm not
real comfortable that I have,
uh,
you know,
like if you have your finger on a gun
and the trigger is very light and you,
you're applying pressure,
but you're very like,
whoa,
this could go off any second.
Now there's that.
Oh,
something goes weird.
that sucks.
It's does.
But if you work out a lot,
you can keep it in check.
Yeah.
I workout,
I lift weights.
I do,
I train and I do like,
uh,
like dead lifts and squats and Shit and
that I love physical labor.
I love using my muscles and uh,
and it,
it,
it takes my anxiety away and it makes
the rage attacks way less.
I feel like I have a lot of
testosterone.
Yeah,
you probably do.
I mean this is probably why you like
threesomes and lot of crazy shit that
some girls wouldn't be into.
Yeah.
But there's nothing wrong with that,
you know,
but as long it's all in like finding
what you need to do to kind of balance
out whatever biological issues.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Because right now at this point,
like I feel like the world doesn't see
the anger attacks when my poor fucking
boyfriend,
I mean,
cause I live with them,
so he's the one that gets the brunt of
it and he cares about me and he'll go do
when this happens.
Do you want me to come upstairs?
Do you want me to ignore you?
I'm like,
I don't know.
I'm sorry
for,
um,
do you ever like do a,
like a boxing class or something?
Did a bar,
a punching bag to kickbox and once and I
cried the whole class.
Why did you cry?
Cause I was like,
I wonder cry.
Yeah,
you're crossing.
Even I was in a good mood that day.
I just,
my friend Melissa like loves kickbox.
She's very athletic and she's like you
should come with me to a tiger shellmans
class.
And I was like okay.
And then I came and all man I went to
town on that punching bag.
I love punching shit over.
Yeah.
Maybe you should do that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean the thing like I yeah I should
take boxing classes.
Just don't like when anybody else's
around cause it Kinda is embarrassing.
Well that's why the rage rooms that we
were talking about before would be,
cause you're in a rage room by yourself.
They don't have them in New York City or
rage room is a place they have you don't
know about.
You would love this room.
My life is men need rage rooms more than
anyone for rage garage.
Okay.
Do you,
would you break shit?
No.
Okay,
so these,
they'll go to a thrift store.
They'll pop by all the,
you know,
away like sweets.
Yeah.
Right.
And you can go in there with a fucking
baseball bat boy.
Yeah.
This is my fantasy.
Oh God.
I mean that's Wayne.
I want to break glass for wasteful,
but yeah,
this seems wasteful to me.
Nah,
I love it.
I like this guy is like half ass and
that he's not trying hard.
He's not mad at all.
He's just trying to fuck these girls.
Girls get together like a rage in me
afterwards.
All my songs,
Nascar.
So he's got some deep roots.
Might have some like hidden rage.
Oh Hey.
I like,
Huh?
Yeah.
This guy's like examining is on a hot
to,
so he's not even angry.
They're faking it.
He's an angry.
The way he's hitting things.
I mean,
if I'm in a rage room,
I do not want there to be cameras.
I like how they put chest protectors on
you.
What?
A bunch of pussies.
Yeah.
Well,
Amen.
Man Hits you the chair.
You're going to be okay.
But there's consequences to raise you.
Fuck No.
The whole idea.
But I want it to destroy some shit and
not have there be any consequences
you should do.
I think you should seriously try to
meditate because I think it would help
you.
Yeah.
Sometimes it makes me angry though.
But then I think you should go to a
martial arts class.
Yeah.
You should do that.
And go take the kickbox.
Go Punch a battle cry.
I bet.
I bet it'll get it out of your system
now.
I bet it will.
Maybe I've screamed,
man.
And then morph.
You never tried yoga.
I Love Yoga.
I do yoga a lot.
I,
I do.
I use the excuse of time.
It does help.
I,
but I like,
um,
like that's why like weightlifting,
like I,
I got up to a point where I was,
I was squatting 175 pounds and it was,
ugh.
It felt so good and it felt like I was,
every cell in my body was working for
something and it,
and I got energy out.
And if I hadn't gotten that energy out,
I would have just had a fucking angered
right
sites.
Your whole endocrine system to the thing
about lifting weights and specifically
like squats and dead lifts and these are
these big giant complex movements,
is that it forces your body to get
stronger in a way that it excites your
hormonal system.
It makes your bones denser.
That's one of the most important things
about it.
Yeah,
it's a great way to combat osteoporosis
is to lift weights.
Oh Shit.
I just like it because it's the one time
like I like physical activity because
you can,
you,
I have to think about the physical
activity I'm doing so I can't stress
about my career.
Is that the only time I don't think
about like getting a head.
I'm just like the I,
it's the only time I'm in the moment
really,
and I love talking to trainers because
you're talking about next is that too in
the moment,
not just tired of her jaws hurting,
hurting.
My boyfriend said to me the other day,
he's like,
you never look me in the eye when we
fuck.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I guess I don't like we have a sex
podcast.
So I think that,
I mean before before we had this sex pot
cast,
it was more freeing for me.
Now I do think of work when I think of
sex because when you have a sex podcast
that is pay my rent.
Yeah.
Well the is the ironic thing about
careers is that especially in a creative
endeavor,
if you think too much about them,
you paralyze yourself.
Yeah.
Like you're paralyzed it creativity
cause you're thinking about advancement
and getting ahead and success instead of
thinking about creative ideas like you
can,
you could definitely like have too much
of one or the other.
I mean you can only think about creative
and never,
never get your career online because you
just never figured out how to monetize
things.
Yeah.
And don't put pressure on the idea.
Like when guys we fucked it just came
out of like,
let's just do this.
We didn't,
I and I,
and I was nervous to do it because the
name was so brash and I knew it was
good,
but I'm like,
damn,
my mom's going to find out.
And I was worried about that.
I hid it from her for two years
successfully.
That's hilarious.
It started getting too big though.
But we honestly,
both of us were like,
no one's going to,
wasn't a shit.
No one's gonna listen to me talk about
my pussy.
So might as well just talk about it and
not care and see the lesson.
That's the way podcasts evolve the best.
When I first started doing it,
me and my friend Brian,
we just started fucking around with a
laptop,
set up a laptop and we're doing it on
ustream and we didn't even have it
uploaded to itunes.
Yeah,
you're just doing this live streaming
thing.
And then people would ask questions and
there was like 200 people watching.
And it was like,
that was the early days.
There was no pressure on it at all.
And then it was like,
oh,
do this every week.
And then every week started building and
building and building.
Then we started getting some numbers in
and it was like,
hmm.
People watching this thing and then it
got weird.
Well it's cool cause like doing your
podcast and you can do every fucking
late night show on television and you
get,
you reach more people because podcasts,
you can hear it anywhere.
There's Internet in the world.
You can get access to it.
That's so powerful.
There's definitely that.
And there's also no one's interrupting
you.
No one's telling you what to talk about.
Like thinking about some of the fucked
up shit we've said in the last couple,
right.
We [inaudible] are fine with it
and pitch like dark shit and just see
the blood draining for their face.
I'm like,
Oh fuck you pussies.
But then you remember you have to be,
Jean has never going to sign onto that
concept.
Yeah.
Hell No.
Different world.
Those people,
those TV people,
they live in a world of tricking dummies
in the middle of the country.
That's what they look for the next three
and a half.
Men like what I get,
what can I need a big bang theory to
shut down these morons throats?
They were really open about it.
They're like a lot of concepts we
pitched.
They're like,
yeah,
but the middle of the country,
they're not going to like,
and there's a lot of great people
in the middle of the country now too.
This is the thing about the middle of
the country.
It doesn't exist anymore because the
middle of the country is the Internet
too.
So like ignorance is,
I mean there's going to be pockets of
ignorance no matter what you do.
And we found that out in
Charlottesville,
like there was a big shocker for a lot
of people.
They didn't know that.
There's still people with fucking Tiki
torches walking on the street talking
about the blend of our fathers and all
this goofy shit.
But you're,
you're finding more and more people.
Like if you tour,
you can go to places like Kansas City.
You run it up.
Cool people,
we were in spokane,
we had a Gig in spokane are spokane,
Washington.
It's awesome though.
Alice,
Great Salt Lake City.
I really love Texas.
Texas is awesome.
Our live show is very to love it,
are going to hate it and I would go to
going to like a more conservative state.
I'm like,
I going to see you.
They liked it.
You're coming.
Exactly.
It's like they found their,
their podcasts that helps them live in
Dallas,
Texas or wherever it may be.
We did a segment called,
we did a segment called sexting theater
and we're like,
who in here?
Sex?
And then when they raised their hand
like,
give me your phone.
I want to,
we do a theatrical interpretation of
their sex.
The raunchiest,
I didn't want to read it.
I was blushing.
Was in Dallas.
This guy's talking about sucking a fart
out of someone's
body.
Like it was our first gay man.
So of course he was.
But I was like,
that's impressive and unexpected.
You were on board with the fart sucking
until you heard it was a man was trying
to take it all in and then he hit me
with gay man and it won't even further
so much
joe fruit of missed that part of my
life.
Of course you have your
finger on the button.
No,
you have a prostate shit in there.
You don't do it after you've eaten a
Burrito.
I agree with you.
No.
Okay.
Wait,
I don't want to like,
I'm going to give you a homework
assignment
for the girl with a bullet for a ring.
That's where bullets belong on jewelry,
but everyone thinks is a cocaine bio.
I'm like,
oh that's a good point.
And
stimulator.
So your prostate is your g spot and you
just put it in.
You just put it in you upset.
So we put it in a knee jerk off.
When I hear men talk about like they
love women when they,
when a woman comes,
it's so hot to them.
I've never experienced that with men
because they're always like,
oh,
this thing I'm telling you,
I can reenact that.
So many times I've seen it,
but when they had,
when my boyfriend has the product that
we use a narrows Ros,
it's a prostate simulator simulator.
It's a Rog,
you shove in there,
it's more like gently glide with
big and a and you put it in and we have
sex orgasm.
Yes.
Like a curve baby day ruined to that.
No,
it's like a,
it's like a mini Dildo for your button.
We were all having a nice time.
No,
but,
and then you have sex,
you do what you gotta do anyway.
And the orgasm for the guy is so much
more intense to the point where I'm
like,
that's the hottest thing I've ever seen
is the hottest thing I've ever seen.
And he likes it.
So you should try it.
Do you have a good orgasm face?
I'm not looking in the mirror.
Why
do you feel it?
Judge her coffin.
Front of the mirror.
Angry or sad.
Oh Wow.
The one we use is,
is black.
I think.
I don't see jess getting a white would
cause lead,
pull it out,
but also
checking the oil.
This podcast on this note,
really fun.
Like I said before,
I think you guys,
you proved to me that you don't have to
be like a famous person to have a very
successful podcast.
And people kept saying that to me.
Like,
oh,
it's oversaturated bullshit.
And I would say,
what about guys?
We fucked those girls came out of
nowhere.
They're
always top 10 I go,
they're kicking ass.
And they're just good.
They just,
they flow together.
You're,
you're having fun together.
Thank you.
It's great.
Every time you mentioned a span of
spiking,
it's really,
you are powerful.
You really got a powerful,
but you got a year,
like you're the,
you're the top podcasts all the time.
One time we were above you and Canada
and everyone freaked down.
They emailed us and they were like,
Holy Shit.
And I just felt like we are not worthy.
Oh my God.
But we appreciate it.
It's nice to earn somebody's respect
that you respect and it's because you,
you,
you have something.
That's good.
I appreciate you guys too,
and I appreciate the fact that you guys
are really good at being yourselves,
you know?
And I think that I'm a professional.
Yeah.
That's
buckets.
You have a huge point though because
that's,
I mean that's what half of our book is
about is about that just being me that
damn,
that's all I'm off.
Right?
Isn't it amazing that that in itself is
incredibly rare?
It,
it makes me sad,
but yes,
but shouldn't make you sad because I
think it's going to be less rare
hemophilia change.
I hope.
I hope so.
I think human beings,
and I think our culture is evolving like
we were talking about like the the
social climate of this happening and how
many things are going on right now and
words that people are not supposed to
use any more and things that people used
to think of as being commonplace and now
thought of as being problematic.
This lot going on.
It does feel like there's this,
there's a shift.
I feel it.
It's,
I think in along with things like this
crispr technology and a bunch of other
probably unforeseen technologies that
are being worked on right now as we
speak.
I think some weird shit is going down in
40 years.
We're all going to be like basketball
players and shifts can be fun.
We're going to be aliens.
I would do that.
I would choose that Crispr,
which go with the big gray head and the
black eyes and
yeah,
that's a hack alien alien would you
like?
They got titties.
Octopus.
You can kill people.
Number one,
I would be purple and metallic.
Those are an aesthetically I would
choose me to be like that chess monster
from things you remember,
the guys on your chest,
you might have more control over your
destiny.
If you could just wham it down on
things.
I wish I could just put it just,
and on that note,
thank you ladies.
Thank.
Thank you so much for having us guys.
We fucked you can get it on itunes and
elsewhere.
Uh,
twitters,
uh,
philanthropy.
Gow Christina Hutch with two ys.
That's it.
Goodbye everybody.
It was so much fun.